welcome everybody we're back for another
i'm not gm speed chess championship match
i'm grand master robert hess alongside me is
my good friend grandmaster mon hamilton amman
we have a great match up ahead don't we yeah this
is gonna be an exciting one robert two people that
i think potentially the community on twitch here
are not as familiar with but for chess players
and professionals alike or anyone following the
over-the-board classical chess scene these names
should not be too unfamiliar especially one of
the names who uh in the last edition of this exact
event robert made it quite far and almost took
down the whole thing yeah she's very used to this
format and remind everybody of what that is it is
a single elimination bracket and there are three
separate time controls the longest time control
is five minutes plus a one second increment
it's followed by three minutes plus one second
increment and finally we get 25 minutes of bullet
chest at one plus one and of course you advance to
the next round where the prize money increases and
elena cash and skaia as a mom was just alluding to
she made it to the final last year where she was
defeated by john bartholomew who is not taking
part this year which may clear the path for her
way to a championship run but of course she must
get through this very tough challenge in round one
she is the 14th seed taking on number three lars
oscar hogg so amman in this matchup here between
two very strong competitors who do you give the
favorite do you have the seed favorite or the
repeating player in elena kashanskaya well the
the interesting thing about this matchup and uh
i just want to point out that i feel like
alina is consistently getting undersold in
these tournaments um if you think back to the i'm
not a gm last uh last edition uh i think she was
jeez i want to say almost like the the last uh
the last seat in terms of favorite to win and
she made it all the way to the finals and gave an
insane performance by the way so just i think it's
someone not to bet against i think elena has
proven herself in all formats people were even
saying oh maybe she'll be impressive in the blitz
in the longer time controls but there's no way she
holds her own bullet absolutely incorrect so if
i've learned one thing it's not to bet against
selena for no apparent reason so be very careful
there she's incredibly incredibly talented and the
bullet portion i was especially impressed with by
her so um lars i know a little bit uh less about
in terms of online play but robert you and
i were discussing some of the ratings that
he's boasting online right now and they sort of
speak for themselves yeah he's 2800 in bullet
and you're just referring to the fact that hey
alina she thought was thought to be the underdog
in the bullet but that one second increment
can make a world of difference and we are off
lars gets the white peas in the first game and we
have my absolute favorite opening yours too aman
the french wow what a what a place to start robert
it's it's like they know it's like they know wow
and alina does usually come quite well
prepared and in this case we have the
winner where you see the situation
the bishop on b4 pins the knight on c3
and now lara says here take my knight i get the
bishop pair and there will be open space to work
with but how about those double pawns of mine
you have a lot of experience playing the french
yeah i was actually wondering whether we would
see c5 because it's i guess the more topical line
right now more of a main line but the the 97 move
order does give you the option to play b6 here
and go for bishop a6 which i thought was her
intention it's often why black inserts knight e7
first but no we're going back to c5 and maybe uh
some of the chat would be a little more familiar
with some of those lines where the white queen
gets down there and ends up taking all the king
side pawns in exchange for black ruining all the
queenside pawns over here so we haven't quite
got that instead it's the h-pawn robert just
just throwing itself up the board these guys
are neglecting beast development yeah and i like
what alina did as a response because if white were
able to push that pawn to h6 then the dark squares
become very vulnerable around the black king side
and guess what only white has the dark sword
bishop so instead alina she played h6 and now
after bishop b5 checked bishop d7 look at this
move a6 it's clear alina wants to use the man's
idea bishop to b5 try to trade those bishops but
not so fast when your opponent g7 is under attack
yeah and this move bishop b5 it might not look
like much by white but if you play bishop d3 right
away bishop a6 would follow so bishop b5 you want
to lure the bishop to the d7 square and then go
back and say look well now you don't have bishop
a6 and you have to waste the move quote unquote
ways to move with a6 in order to complete that
idea completely agreed and when you play move like
a6 you look at the b6 square next to it it becomes
a little more vulnerable because a pollen's best
friend is another pawn so black very likely after
c4 will try to advance some pawns on the queen
side but we'll see if that's enough for alina to
actually kind of unleash her pieces because right
now look at that bishop on d7 in particular that
is a french bishop if i've ever seen one stuck
behind the wall of ponds yeah that's a that's a
tough wall to be behind but um it is par for the
course in these kind of positions i have to say
like i always look at these positions and think
white has is doing so well because you know this
g pawn is going to get up there at some point
queen f4 g4 but black sometimes puts this bishop
i was going to say puts this bishop on a4 and it
looks like a funny move but hits that pawn on c2
stops white from playing a4 which you know would
be a dream to get that bishop on a3 on that long
diagonal and you know slowly but surely b5 a5 b4
might happen in the future and i'm currently
wondering he was rook a2 and i think that
may have been a bit too defensive i'm looking at
knight h4 and i'm trying to dislodge this knight
from f5 to win the g7 pawn but now it's a move
too slow because if you're playing knight h4 i
have knight c6 to e7 so i can reinforce the 995
that's exactly what alina does i think that she
has a pretty dream position with the superior
pawn structure and now the stable knight on f5
absolutely and now if you if you exchange of
course the other knight is going to appear there
and if you ever move the queen and play g4 and
kick the knight out keep in mind that there's no
way there'll still be an attack on g7 so alina has
sort of stabilized this king probably either gonna
walk to the queenside or even long castle but
both look pretty safe behind this impressive uh
wall of pawns here and i think going forward who
has the advantage it's probably about level i see
the evaluation bar on screen says well zeros which
that doesn't mean anything this isn't a dead draw
there's plenty of life left but it'll be dictated
by who controls the pawn breaks and we've been
talking about b5 a5 maybe a b4 break for black on
the queen side perhaps white will move that queen
like we just have seen in g4 f4 maybe f or
g5 it's a very complex position full of rich
ideas and it's closed for now but don't be
surprised when this whole board opens up
definitely yeah we're gonna see the pawns move
up the board remember white has the bishop pair
whenever you have the bishops you gotta try to
open things up so whether it's g4 g5 whether it's
g4 f4 f5 uh something has to give here and um and
lars oscar has a rook tied down on the queen side
but otherwise his prospects on the king side look
pretty good here yeah and i like your plan though
mon castle queen side because black can also play
on the king side with her pawn she can strike
back with the time the f6 or g6 when the moment
feels right but she instead goes queen b5 and
is queen bee one a big threat here hitting the
rook in the bishop i absolutely think so queen
b1 is it's a hilarious move getting behind enemy
lines um even if you played queen b1 and rook b2
happen you can even go to a1 and just sort of hang
out there for the moment which would be nuts but
castles by white and i was wondering what was
going to happen after rook b2 like is she going
to go queen a5 then she might but i i feel like
you're kind of toned there suggested you don't
like the queen sitting on a5 it's far away from
the rest of the board so i wonder if she thought
she could play queen to b1 and she would have
been able to had that pawn did on a7 rather than
on a6 because the queen needs to stay in touch
with the pawn on b6 and thus couldn't use your
idea of queen b1 queen a1 without dropping that
pawn yeah and now that that the i guess the idea
queen b5 didn't work out for black uh what i see
is that that's just been a massive waste of time
and white's got castle kicked the queen out with
the rook got an f5 in f6 is the next idea if it
can happen and i think lars has opened up what
could be a pretty significant advantage here
unless alina reacts pretty aggressively right now
because the move f6 robert i feel like white gets
that in it's you may as well resign well you say
if white gets that in i agree with you then black
is just strategically so why shouldn't black play
f6 there it is because white has castle kingside
even if it costs you a pawn breaking open the
king's side was a king on g1 and that king could
be susceptible to a counter attack i like this
move f6 a lot as amman was highlighting if white
played it there's this destruction down the f-file
instead the board can blow open at any moment and
we'll see to whose advantage it is bishops tend
to thrive with an open board right but the king is
over there so that's the trade-off yeah and and
keep in mind that when things start to open up
on the king side potentially alina is going
to be the one with more firepower over there
because this rook is tethered to the c2 pawn
and isn't doing anything on the b file so it's
basically just kind of stuck on the queen side now
you could say the bishop is stuck as well but from
black's perspective you're kind of putting three
points over there and tying down five points if
you think of it mathematically so that could be
something good for for lena as things open up but
i'm always concerned about what the bishops can do
in an open position completely with you there and
i will add that i think for many people in our
audience rook f1 to b1 would make sense because
you're doubling rooks and hitting the b6 pawn but
note that black has a very easy response in b6 to
b5 putting the pawn on the square defended by
another pawn and that bishop and the queen so
i'm just saying you attacked me i simply defended
now your rooks are useless over there so the rook
on b2 as amman was highlighting that doesn't
want to be there would much prefer to be on f2
over on the king side but that journey would
drop the c2 pawn so not happening anytime soon
right queen d7 played here and i mean uh i
think that uh lars could sort of approach this
position a bit so it's not it's not like anybody
has to take uh the pawns in the current position
there's a lot of tension and what what i see it
at some of the lower levels robert is as soon
as there's tension it's gone so it's there for a
move and as soon as you can take something it's
so tempting to just relieve that tension and
make things easier to calculate but oftentimes
keeping the tension is is how you build things up
so right now we can see neither player willing to
bite because if white takes on e6 black is happy
to take back with the queen and all of a sudden
the queen is you know pinning that jeep
on putting pressure on e5 more centralized
so neither player is looking to give any ground
here no indeed not and it's a really good lesson
in when you should capture when you should
leave the tension as it is and look at this
now that the rook went to f8 the pawn on f6 was
captured but i'm still looking at this and it
was smart of lars to put the king on h1 but
shouldn't black just now play f5 and continue
breaking open more lines in front of the white
king this rook on d2 is the biggest problem on
the board because all of black's pieces can come
to the king side for the attack and this rook on
b2 is a bystander on the queen side and end games
will also be problematic for white because of this
double pawns on c3 and z2 yeah love this move
though uh queen g3 sort of inviting the move f4
and f4 closes off that diagonal but it also
strangely enough it keeps things closed on
the king side which might be exactly what lars
needs just a little bit of time to regroup his
pieces maybe he brings the queen back uh defends
c2 and then suddenly he can reroute that rook
over to the open e file that's a great idea right
queen the g2 hits d5 brings the rook back around
and i like what alina is doing instead of playing
f4 and speaking of tension that would remove the
tension of these pawns over there on the f and g
files she's keeping that tension alive protects
her c7 with the rook she needs to keep up the rook
and f8 where it is because the b8 square and that
queen and bishop battery can be quite powerful
and look at this a queen trade being offered
and if you're a lena do you take there because i
feel like i don't want to get into the end game
well there's a few things to keep in mind like
there's almost rook sacrifices that work both of
these rooks are on full-time duty protecting
c7 and b8 so she plays the the more i guess
aggressive move queen queen h4 this is really
going to enter some some tactical waters here the
rook is being defended by the queen and you know
everything's barely under control here chung b6 oh
my god whoa you see you shake her head she's like
oops forgot about that pawn and that rook on b2
it wasn't doing anything for so long and then you
drop an important pawn in front of your king yeah
earlier it you were like guys i know some of the
low-rated people in the chat might suggest just
attacking the bond but there's an easy defense
and queen takes a6 rook a7 wait did you see the
evaluation bar it just went much lower because
it wait what is happening here hang on a sec
because i think the move by the way was rook
takes e7 yes and then there was queen a6 and
bishop takes d5 so that's what was missed but
look at the time two seconds there's only plus
one in this game and uh rupees mate ruiz mate oh
my gosh of maiden one on the board lose on time oh
oh my god he forgot about his clock two two
seconds is by the time your opponent moves and
the the game it's suddenly your turn for
you to process their move think of your move
decide on your move and execute your move that's
a lot more than two seconds for most people
oh my gosh we should pull up that just to
show the final position there was checkmate
in one available on the board with rook all the
way down to b8 checkmate and look at that 18
seconds spent on rook takes f3 and it's almost
like you just don't calculate that move at all
and then you you would never expect a blunder of
made in one that's a long way to go for the mouse
there robert you know as somebody who loses them
time very regularly in my blitz games i get it
and actually perhaps rook takes f3 was a brilliant
choice by elena in a position where her king is in
trouble no matter what no easy moves for lars and
checkman one of course is the best move but hard
to accomplish but as we get to this second game
here i mean many missed tactics from both sides as
you're just pointing out this checkpoint showing
that rook takes e7 from earlier but i think we
chalk up that entire game down to you know just
just round one that's that's what you get in round
one robert nobody was comfortable there it's funny
to see the reactions i was actually looking at the
webcams of the two players after that made in one
miss and we saw lars who actually didn't get to to
play it in flag he was he was laughing he thought
that was pretty funny like he seemed in good
spirits and alina was stone-faced like yep just
just yeah that's a win for me let's go next game
alina is all about that serious business in this
tournament last year she's very friendly you know
she's a great person but she takes this seriously
and she wants to beat every single opponent
that is in front of her she is a professional in
the truest definition of the world a word excuse
me so in how we get into the game too she's up
a pawn because of the opening it was a banco
gambit named after pa pal benko he played this
where you get a lot of play for sakura's pawn
but i don't think this is the ideal setup for
lars because well where are you actually getting
that play e4 is defended a4 is your extra pawn
and that's a pass pawn i don't see the typical
weaknesses that black can target so i'm not sure i
really would enjoy this position from lars's point
of view especially being down a point in the match
maybe you feel some pressure to win immediately
yeah um well first of all i think that the idea
is mainly d5 like when black plays e6 like this
in the benko and allows white to take
he's pretty much got to get the move d5
in at some point and if he doesn't i think
it's just problematic usually what i'm used
to is black actually plays like rook a6 and gets
the queen over to that diagonal and that helps a
lot with d5 but the way that this has happened i
i just feel like alina has gotten a good version
of maybe a theoretical one that i'm familiar with
so i think she should be happy here remember these
are five minute games so lots and lots of time to
dissect this position what happens after h6 knight
takes e6 c4 first question there could be some
kind of knight d4 type of move when you continue
running the knight around but i then i see queen
c5 and those are the type of things where your
knights hang in the center of the board so
h6 actually is a good move and i don't think
knight takes e6 as possible so you'd have to drop
your knight back but let me ask you something is
h6 inducing more weaknesses and so that's one
of the reasons she went for it or do you think
she just overlooked h6 and now lars has to
find it i think i think she overlooked it
but i think it's the type of movie overlook where
you're not that upset and he he does play it i
think she goes back pretty quickly here realizes
look this is just not playable um and she's not
gonna be too unhappy going back because she sees
that there are those weaknesses you talked about
yeah and it's one of these positions i would
say where you sort of trust your opponent
h6 could be a huge blunder but knight takes e6
you then see c4 i think she's very well aware that
this is not going to work out so she's quickly
going to dismiss that now she's trying to figure
out should my knight go to h3 where it defends my
pawn on f2 or should i just go back to f3 where
it came from but now there could be some issues
down the file so she does choose the retreating
square that she came from but i could see why you
would start considering your options at that point
right and knight g4 chosen so a bit of a different
route it looks like there won't be d5 anymore it's
more gonna be like a knight to e5 type of game
rook takes f3 is is tempting but i think knight e5
maybe try to sink that knight on d3 with c4
hitting the f2 pawn is the way to go here
how about the other knight to e5 because that way
you could maybe throw in a rook takes f2 check if
i i don't know if that will work
but knight takes e5 rook f2 check
does look very appealing to me yeah that's
fantastic because now whoa now it takes king g1
and alina wants to say look no matter how you
take that back your rook is loose there what's
going on here yeah so she can take with the uh
he's a dick with the bishop and then she can take
the knight on g4 but then her bishop on d2 falls
here so a lot it's really messy but black has to
be happy about this with a very strong bishop
and the white king on g1 is in serious danger
because i would have said on the last move when
the bishop was hit and the knight was hit like if
you just move the bishop there something like
i don't know bishop f4 or somewhere then the
knight's being hit and you can't move it because
the the rook on f2 but this just looks winning for
for black yeah the evaluation bar i just saw it
sync and it's saying just completely winning for
black and you still have to put these games away
absolutely i just don't see any way for black
to go wrong unless you somehow hang up your g6
pawn if i don't know how that would even happen
but it feels like it's just too easy at
this point for black to play so there's no
concern for lars whatsoever and he will even
this match up at one game apiece yeah it's really
looking like that but we've seen in the last game
where it came down to a maiden one right where uh
he wasn't able to convert it just because of the
time so we'll have to keep our fingers crossed
that doesn't happen to him again but rook end game
this is looking really really promising for him
yes because it's essentially you know three extra
pawns in the center for that one pass work at six
now i didn't actually like the decision to go in
the end game and this is exactly why your rook hat
is tied down to the a pawn now your pawns on
the sixth rank there are four of them there
and this that lonely rook on f6 is going to start
chopping them off yeah so i i like to move rook
e2 um the engine gave some crazy brook af1 move
but other than that move taking on g6 is logical
and i think black is kind of back in the
driver's seat like this pawn can get to a7 but
this rook can't really help out it's hard to make
that guy queen yeah and now this rook goes to c7
so black's pawns are kind of stopped and white has
the more active rooks a rook behind a past pawn
is excellent and now that pawn can even go to a7
where the rook on c7 does double duty of stopping
black's past pawn and protecting white's past pawn
freeing up the a1 rook although the king on h1
there are back ranked checkmate possibilities
perhaps that rook if it does leave the first
rank then black will then counter to try to
checkmate white yep because basically after rook
a7 i mean you're always thinking about rook b1 and
rook b8 after that but this seems difficult for
for white because i feel like when you
move that rope there's always rook a2
yeah that's true as well and that way you
can get your rook behind the pawn and stop it
so what does white really need here i'm trying to
think which pawns you need to pick off to have a
chance to hold this the e6 pawn feels like an
important it gets a rookie one and after rook
a2 maybe rook c6 just double up on that e6 pawn
and try to win it uh but even if you get that one
it's still plenty of well the nice thing is that
if you can orchestrate that you take with the rook
from the first rank and then if king g5 you
have rook g6 mate so the king has to go back
and then maybe you can try checking forever or
something like that that's a really good point
because king g5 here would be a great move but
white can play rook g7 check and then the king
would have to go back to f6 so your idea
about that king being in a sort of net
played a big role in that position and that's why
lars puts his king in e5 and then his king go to
d4 where it's safe and sound surrounded
by these pawns that help shield the king
yeah and keep in mind sometimes uh if you're not
careful this king might go to e4 and f3 and i'll
almost go for some checkmate ideas against the
king on h1 this king uh elena's king like if
it was more in the game or if these pawns were
were not doubled they would change the position
entirely but these pawns on the g file pretty
much don't exist and the king as she finally
brings it into the action is just so far away uh
black's basically playing with an extra attacker
that's right and here your idea of rook a2 speaks
to me just get your rook behind the pawn to force
white into defensive posturing you need to defend
that pawn she put c3 first but now rook e6 to c6
yeah and now both sides are struggling to beat
three or what but then you go rook b3 now you're
in a passive setup maybe rook takes h6 as possible
i took away your ability to play pawn to c2
and then i could run my g-pawn up the board i
would i would be worried about this king d3 d4
connecting but yeah i mean i guess you just gotta
trust it and just go for it the jeep on the a-pawn
this is gonna be wild i've liked the rook on
b2 keeping the white king on the first rank
and i thought that maybe you could try to get
that other rook in for a checkmate i guess there
was never time to make that work and here how do
you deal with this you're right though that pawn
just feels to me like black should win this game
is you we always learn in chess the two connected
past ones always beat the split past puns yeah
and you're right the slip pawns are good in king
and pawn end games because the king can sit in
front of connected pawns and stop them whereas the
split ones the king can't get both the same
times like bowling and here in the rook on a3
it's winning the a7 pawn by force the
c3 pawn is defended by the opponent d4
once a7 falls that's very easy it's not even split
pawns anymore it's just your double pawns in the g
file yeah very past connected pawns yeah and
this this doesn't look promising that the
eight pawn is gonna drop you can trade a pair
of rooks chuck your rook in front of the pond
if necessary and the king and the pawns just march
up the board so i think just trade the rooks and
you know we're only two games in but it's too
early to make any kind of big claims but what
i will say is from these two games lars has been
more tactically alert than alina has and in the
first game alina just dropped that v6 pawn right
it was under attack she just didn't see it she's
like what what's wrong with me how did i miss that
of course i'm too strong to fall for that and lars
was able to pick that off and in this game he
found knight d7 e5 taking on f2 and all that
stuff so i feel like thus far elena you know she
needs to be a bit more cautious in these tactical
positions and i hope she's not getting down on
herself because just two games in two games of
blitz we all make plenty of mistakes just getting
started here um obviously the first game is
a little bit of a the jitters there rook a7 little
uh trick at the end but yeah just for g8 is gonna
be that's gonna be it so we have a tied match one
to one and so far i think uh i think we're in for
a treat in this match robert as the the opening
for the second game already switched up he he
didn't want any part of of that french at least
for now yeah i think it's really cool when we get
these matches and every game is different because
sometimes you see great theoretical discussions
and battles but then as commentators can we get
a new position just so we can be as shocked as
everybody else so here this knight on d2 this kind
of variation says instead of the jibawa london
type of thing with knight c3 white can still play
pawn to c4 and elena takes towards the center but
that also means that her castling kings side will
be more difficult for black because the king will
lack one of its shields right pawns in front of a
king help defend it here that pawn is towards the
center but an open g-file could spell trouble
if the king decided to venture that way yep
yeah there's always that decision you take with
the epon or the g-pawn and this entire opening
that lars has played here the trombosky it's is
designed to quickly take that knight on f6 and
and force black to make this kind of uncomfortable
decision so long term positionally speaking that h
pawn is loose and i'm not so sure about the move
e4 or even the move c4 to be quite frank because
this d-pawn to me always is going to require some
attention and you know that dark square bishop is
is in alina's possession and there's nothing to
match it uh from white's position in some ways
it's hard to hold yourself back but i'm completely
with you and as you know we've seen many queens
gambit accepted types of positions where you want
to play e4 and take firm control over the center
but then your pawn on d4 doesn't have its best
friend on e3 protecting it you don't get to build
that pawn chain so that's why we're saying e4 may
have been a little bit too much too helpful for
black to put permanent pressure along the d file
and well how to go from here f5 comes to my mind
i have double pawns i don't like my double pawns
maybe i'll try to just hammer at your center and
i guess bishop h6 i have a bishop move i don't
have to play e6 and develop on that diagonal let
me use the diagonal i currently have and get
my bishop out that way yeah it's because such
a funny move bishop h6 is like imagine you take
this pawn back and they go bishop takes d2 it's
like every piece that you could take on d2 with
blunder is one of these central pawns it seems
right and i think that clearly evidences the big
drawback of playing e4 rather than e3 is that
some pieces are she plays bishop h6 i thought
there it is they need to defend these two pawns
and the knight on d2 is protecting e4 if you
replace that 92 with the other knight to keep
e4 defended you drop d4 that's a monster central
point here and i like black's position i think
it's just much more confusing to play this from
white's perspective yeah i i think at this point
you start getting concerned that you're not going
to get that pawn back and maybe you decide to go
queen a4 check just take that back say okay look
let's even the material before we go any further
and then look to just go wish me too in castle but
gotta like these two bishops as you know a lot of
pressure on the center that knight is going
to get developed either to to c6 or c697 and
kingside castling for black even though there's
a g takes f6 played in this position i think it's
fairly safe i'm with you now i was mentioning how
you sometimes struggled the castle king said when
you move the pawn from that side of the board but
with your bishops there and good luck attacking
the black king and especially because the central
pawns are weak oftentimes if you're getting
attacked you can try to counter in the center
of the board distract your opponent's forces and
that's clearly what's happening right now and lars
is almost a minute behind at this point alina this
is for both of them it's not a position they could
have expected this is pretty new territory and
i just feel like it's easier to play
with the bishop pair at this point
yeah and i was going to mention one idea h4 to
like trap the bishop there's always this bishop
d2 to get out of it um and what he's done is he's
just given up that pawn that we were talking about
in the center and he's looking to play from here
i i can't say that this looks good at all i mean
knight c6 you got all the dark squares
and now alina could say look i'm going to
castle queenside i don't even need to deal with a
potential attack over here i'm with your partner
and it's kind of funny i forgot that one of the
most important roles in this position was the
bishop on g6 defending f7 because typically the
queen goes to b3 with a double attack on b7 and
f7 but f7 was already defended so queen b
only attacked one pawn that was easy to defend
perfect and we see kingside castling i think
because if black castles queen side at least
lars is kind of happy to see an imbalance in the
position at least he can throw his pawns up there
but 95 hitting the bishop again watching that
f7 square just a tender square in the position
and i mean it's looking better and better for for
alina as she's basically collected an absolutely
and totally free pawn in the opening yeah i think
black's next two moves might be castle queenside
which attacks the knight on d2 and that rook on
h8 can come to g8 and i was talking about how that
open file can help whiten attack if black castles
that way but because black is casting in the other
direction she can use her rook to go to g8 and
put some immediate pressure on white's king
and this just looks overwhelmingly good for elena
kashlin's guy here yeah i was gonna say probably
castle first and then play queen d3 i was
a big fan of but queen e3 exact same idea
why wouldn't you want to trade queens i mean
like you're you're up upon just uh we've all
learned that one of the easiest ways to convert
whenever you're up material simply trade yeah
and simply trade you know the one thing that
white could potentially use the c file no there's
a knight md3 saying no c1 square for you and
this is very very good for alina but i will say
these are the types of positions that frustrate
me sometimes where i know i should with best play
be close to winning already but then proving that
is a totally different story so what actual plan
would you go for here my first instinct is rook d4
or other other d8 and just take over the open file
but i i'm trying to figure out what the long term
strategy should be yeah i think i think in general
i mean like a trait of knights i feel like would
be fantastic she's just gonna go for the the very
slow modest doubling of the rooks um i like that
this knight hits the b2 pawn so i would try to
leave that night there double the rooks and then
i feel like it at the right moment you know once
you get like c5 in or c6 you can start thinking
about just b5 and even collecting on b2 i agree
and for white i would consider playing g4 at
some point to try to lock in that bishop on g6
i don't want to see that bishop open up after
move like pawn f6 to f5 because the bishop gets
some new life but g4 has its own wrist and you
give the f4 square to the knight and the f3 pawn
also is going to be quite weak so uh rook d2
lara says you double i'm going to do the same and
yeah let's let's fight for this file and there
we go f5 that's just a good move and after this
i'm not concerned about her winning chance anymore
as soon as she gets that move in opening up that
bishop getting rid of her double pawns i'm all for
it so maybe something like takes takes knight e3
followed by f4 and you're threatening like f5 g4
um locking that bishop out of the action and you
know if you play f6 or something then all of a
sudden this bishop e6 is in the position that's
a really good call and i think that was better
than what just happened because now black should
play bishop e6 your move 93 was very frustrating
because the pawn f7 the bishop on b3 opens up
let me start by playing bishop e6 and that way if
you move your knight i simply trade bishops what
were we talking about hey let's trade pieces we're
up a full pawn and i mean you're calling it and
she's delivering on on demand here robert bishop
e6 ready for trades here this knight basically can
cannot be attacked to any degree where it's going
to need to move and if it if it needs to it can
always go back to one of these lovely squares and
it'll open up potential trades on the d file so
this is this is tough because in the in the last
position i was thinking maybe you start running
the pawns but now there's not really any specific
targets uh that lars can hit in this position
and there are tactics available for alien as
well bishop takes c4 for my knight takes b2
because that knight is defended on b2 tactically
as the rook on d2 can't move to the side otherwise
the rook behind it falls however that would be
a very committal decision by elena because with
her bishop coming off the board the pawn on f7 may
not seem so important but the idea being that now
we have pawns on both sides of the board bishops
tend to be better than knights in those situations
because bishops are long-range pieces and knights
take a while to go from one side to the other
it's a really important point that robert's
highlighting that although black can win upon
here with the tactic he outlined white takes on
f7 and there's gonna be a past pawn that white
can create on the king side and you just have
to be so so careful because the bishop can sit
on g8 and defend the black pawn that's pushing
while helping a white bomb that's pushing over
here so um what just happened rook d4 knight e3
so i expect that bishop takes b3 certainly on the
cards one thing you got to be careful of robert
is now that rook is not on a square that you can
well that's defended basically so if that knight
gets attacked um one more time it could just be
pinned to the road yeah that's actually a problem
and i look at the clock what's the problem for
white is not just the pawn deficit 20 seconds left
for lars so he is getting down on the clock he is
just down in the position but we'll see if he's
able to find some kind of rook a5 rook h5 swing
that rook around attack some pawns and that's
the problem with isolated ponds the h7 pawn
it's not that easy to defend you'd have to use a
more valuable piece just to save that measly pawn
absolutely night before rookie two and now we see
just good technique uh from molina she's got the
she's got the rook in and maybe just bring your
work back to d3 when the b3 pawn i understand why
she traded the rooks here i guess rook d okay she
could have gone after b3 but said she's just tying
white's pieces down and now knight f4 check
rook to d3 next i think she yeah she's got
ripped d3 and now now once you take this pawn
rook takes b2 as a threat or you can start
with knight d3 either one yeah she chooses
the fancy way i i support that look good
and yeah the apon night end games so tricky so
underrated but i feel like three connected pass
pawns they kind of worked for lars in that last
game robert you think elena's gonna be all right
here she will but she has to watch out for pawn
h6 for white knight f6 and if she loses the h7
pawn all of a sudden lars has some hope and look
at the clock she is actually down on time all of
a sudden i don't know where that came from oh me
neither but her pawns are too fast they must be v3
is crushing yeah but she's worried i mean she must
be worried about the h7 pawn b2 now a3 yeah we're
on the same page completely partner and that's
just that it's just too it's it's too comfortable
when you're when you're up in the commentary booth
and it's good that she calmed herself there she
was getting low on time that laser focused uh cam
that you see on alina catching sky is exactly what
uh helped her help bring home the point for her
there yeah and her technical abilities have proven
very strong both in last year's edition of this
tournament and so far here it looks good and now
we have a dutch so we really are getting different
openings every game that's very exciting for me
and i'm sure for you as well and for our fans and
all right this position let's try to explain what
it's all about black has put upon f5 that could
be weakening to the king side you look at that
diagonal there could be some options there the e6
square in particular if white pushes that pawn to
d5 maybe you can take advantage and try to put a
knight on e6 because no pawns defend the squares
but iman why don't we talk about what black
has going for him in a position like this
yeah it's really dependent on the setup a lot of
times black goes queen eight we see queen c7 both
of these moves have the same idea you sort of want
to hint at the possibility of potentially playing
e5 at some moment so knight d7 could help that a5
is just restricting things on the queen side but
if you're not going for e5 a lot of times you
can play these positions a lot slower you can
sort of play like king h8 bring your bishop to
e6 and g8 and this is a really solid structure if
white ever plays e4 you're looking to take right
away maybe get that bishop out to f5 with tempo
the knight follows to d7 so it can be a really
comfortable position for black to just sort of
sit back and wait for white to commit pawns to
certain squares as we see already the queen side
initiative by black he says forget development
i'm pushing a5 a4 and looking to open up
that a file yeah which is just trying to get rid
of the undeveloped pieces in the on the queen side
look at that rook the knight in the bishop so
if you can trade rooks maybe that's beneficial
but you don't want to hand over the open file
to alina's work either so knight a6 is played
and i guess knight d7 would have been more typical
going towards the center but then where would that
bishop on c8 go so black's pieces to some extent
stepping on each other's toes and look at this
alina takes some a4 saying you know why i put my
bishop on c3 so i can push that double a4 pawn to
a5 and it's going to be defended over there yeah
i think that was just an oversight by by lars you
you generally do not want to let this happen when
the pawn can just go to a5 and be defended because
now she's going to plant the rook on b1 generally
speaking hit the b-pawn and lara's saying i don't
care forget the queen side i'm going rookie e5 as
i mentioned earlier what do we make of this i have
to say lena has got to have the better position
but you know the bishop is going to go back to
c8 from lars it's going to defend b7 so the rook
on b1 is not really going to be doing anything
the rest of the game and there's always pressure
on that d-pawn if you ever take the knight makes
it in the game i love that move though c5 and that
is actually quite standard in a position like this
the pawn on d6 is not defended by a pawns defended
by a piece the queen so if i can take on d6 i will
get a tempo against that queen so that's why pawn
takes d4 for black doesn't just win a pawn and if
pawn e4 i'll throw in pawn takes d6 as well that
way i don't allow the position to be locked up in
here don't take on c5 go take towards the center
probably d takes e5 here looks good but i think
that the tactical nature of this should make lars
feel like he's a chance especially with the d5
square available to that knight on f6 yep don't
forget that both knights now have some squares
to sort of jump around to knight d5 knight b4 um
i will say i think that elena is is just better
after taking and maybe save that bishop or go a3
kind of looks like a funny move but take control
that b4 square eventually white's going to go
e4 and if everything takes there the d6 square
anchored with that pawn on e5 is going to
be pretty juicy for alina if she's really
having a think here i think she's maybe
giving consideration to pawn takes c5
um but i'm kind of wondering because if you take
on e5 with the knight it just doesn't look right
giving up d4 here yeah i agree with you and i
think another thing to point out is the c4 square
is now free you have vacated it by pushing your
pawn forwards the knight would love to land there
so if d takes e5 followed by knight c4 hey that
e5 pawn and the a5 pawn are both defended by that
powerful knight on c4 which is trying to go
into d6 and wreak havoc in black's position
yeah so she's giving a long think there i think
she came up with the best uh decision overall
and she wants everything basically like she can
get a3 knight c4 this game is all but over but
you mentioned how tactical lars has appeared to
be in the match so far robert do you think he's
just gonna go for f4 here try to get that bishop
out and just try to get some energy going on the
on the king side because the position looks kind
of rough otherwise you mentioned knight c4 that
looks so strong yeah positionally black is toast
and black is down a pawn so bishop e6 i'm i'm with
you i think that an a3 you have this completely
under control i think that even though he didn't
do it right away he must go f4 i don't actually
see an attack but perhaps the threat of the attack
is enough considering this is a blitz game and
mistakes happen much more regularly in blitz
alina is a great player lars is a great player
as well but you can't just sit here when you're
down upon the knights coming to c4 into d6 the
b7 pawn is target your knight on a6 is a donkey
because the b4 square is now covered by the pawn
a3 so everything is looking favorable for white
so you just need to mix it up because
otherwise you'll just get rolled over here
if white gets to have everything that she wants
now and i mean e3 if white gets to play e3
as well as knight c4 this game is a role it's it's
completely over so you have to get something going
a3 is just a dagger move to play it might not
look like much but you mentioned the donkey on a6
lars is probably thinking and he's like oh my
goodness why didn't i just throw knight before it
i don't know why didn't i just play f4 when
i had the chance because now i think it's
now or never robert if not f4 i think elena has
this game she's up on time as well completely
agreed and one more thing i'll add queen takes a5
may seem like a free pawn at first but you dropped
the b7 pawn and that would be devastating
so look at these last two moves bishop e6
and then bishop back to c8 spending about a minute
and 40 seconds between the two and alina doesn't
need to think at this moment because well her
position is so good i would play e3 and just yeah
he's rerouting that knight to d7 trying to
put pressure there but again it's just a
non-threat you can also play knight move and pawn
to f4 for a while i like that move though knight
b6 that's that's just nice ouch the queen gets
trapped if you take the knight that's hilarious
i'm just gonna put that on the board that is a
funny looking trap and the queen is looking at
the the knight in bishop like whose side are you
one and you know what's funny about this knight
a8 was like almost trapping the queen as well so
oh oh my goodness oh she just stole the c5 pawn so
the knight going back to b8 removed the defender
of the pawn on c5 and now she's up two full pawns
yeah knight g5 or knight d4 are going to be you
know some of the next moves considered here the
d5 knight is going to be in real real trouble i
mean this is a matter of time i i feel like she's
playing fantastic at the moment and lars is just
he's just defending he's just on the back foot
and knight g5 played and this is just all
sorts of problematic you win that bishop
on e6 you trade it for that knight then remember
how we talk about the dutch it opens up the king
look at that diagonal i would love to take your
knight on d5 and then start putting pressure on
the diagonal so just take it with a pawn on v6
yeah take with the pawn and then you could even
take on e6 and just go f4 or you could start with
f4 but as soon as you play f4 i guess it's just
over it locks absolutely all this firepower
aimed at e5 that you see in this position
f4 just says nope it's as simple as that a one
word response you know when you ask your parents
when you're younger can i do something and then go
nope yep that's it all right yeah i'm just gonna
put my head down run back to my room
that's that yeah that's what f4 does
i'm not gonna waste my time trying
to convince this one's a lost cause
yeah i would play f4 here i wonder if she's just
trying to make sure her king doesn't get in any
future danger but there are no pieces to attack
with as you said all of them are biting on granite
because they're staring at the e5 pawn which
is defended by another pawn and this is a clear
illustration of why we always say a pawn's best
friend is another pawn a one point piece defends
another one point piece while all of black's heavy
pieces are staring into that which is defended
and because alina is playing so well right
now it's it's tough to even find criticism so
i'll offer one is i feel like she's so calculated
almost to a detriment that in positions like this
where it's so intuitive uh she eats up a lot of uh
clock time playing moves that you could play you
know kind of in a more flowy fashion a little bit
quicker and lars always ends up making the game
close in a time scramble now last time remember we
looked at the clock and we were like wait a minute
how is she the one lower on time now she still
converted the game and that's that's definitely
her style but just pointing that out is something
to keep an eye on for the rest of this match as
she consistently gets these dominating positions
but maybe maybe needs to play a little bit more
intuitively when she's got the upper hand we see
the engine at pretty much plus five right now
yeah i agree with you for example there she could
take on e6 instead of putting her knight back in
f3 she did 93 very quickly so that's good but some
of the decisions i feel like she can just play and
trust herself and that's a key factor in blitz is
how much confidence you have and are you trusting
your instinct sometimes we trust our instincts
and fail miserably right i've done that many times
where like oh this sacrifice looks good and wait a
sec nope it just fails to this simple response and
look at this move by by lars c5 it doesn't change
the balance of the game white is so much better
here but at least it complicates things and that
is what lars has been doing well now he's trying
to go knight d7 at some point when the b6 pawn
guess what you can't play knight d7 there's a
rook on d1 covering the open file so the position
is miserable but it's really what we're talking
about right now is not about this specific moment
but how this match will continue what the trends
are like and i do think that ultimately alina is
playing extremely well here but i'm with you that
sometimes she gets herself in a little bit too
much trouble than the position calls for this is
just surgical at the moment there's no other word
for it i mean every move from alina has just been
top-notch right now and lara's even coming in with
a pre-move there bishop c4 the queen strapped oh
no it's a4 sorry it has the bishop d5 check look
at that beautiful move great and that's going to
win the the rook on c6 actually no not quite not
quite bishop takes there's going to be bishop
takes back and here's that 15 seconds ticking
down lars is dead in the water it's plus 10 but
hey just 10 seconds left anyone can flag is what
we've learned so far yes and she's doing a good
job because lars pieces can't move with queens
back out but she needs to move she's six seconds
this is what we're saying what are you doing
exactly you gotta go for two seconds i don't know
how did she even one second go oh my gosh she lost
some time she forgot look at her reaction and lars
is like what i'm saying did you see lars he goes
did i do that he's like what just happened and
that was the most winning position you could
ask for and we are going to take a break we have
that midway point in the longest time patrol
here but aman i'm beside myself we were just
highlighting that you can't spend so much time in
positions that she should just trust herself in
what can we make of that i i said it and i brought
it up for a reason um because she was doing so
many good things that i mean she's not a perfect
player we have to highlight maybe one of her only
weaknesses and positions like that and she
gets so involved with the calculations and
they're all brilliant we saw even at the very
end with 10 seconds we were looking at bishop
d6 oh so impressive puts the queen back on e8
but lars he plays queen a8 in about 0.3 seconds
and meanwhile she's taking 10 seconds for queen
f7 he plays queen a6 in 0.1 seconds and then
she flags and that's gonna be something to look
in the entire match watch out for that because
she is outplaying lars significantly right
now but robert this cannot keep up she has
to trust herself more in positions and start
using instincts this is blitz after all i will
just say that if you know you believe in karmic
balance the fact that lars lost the first game on
time in a position he had checkmated one maybe
this is kind of payback for that that if she
loses on time in completely winning position i
would say the first two games i would give the
nod to lars these last two games alina has played
great chess it is a two-two match we will take a
short break and when we return we'll have the
latter half of this longest time five minute
plus one second increment portion of i'm not a gm
speeches championship brought to you by chess.com
well we barely had time to catch our breath i
hope the players were able to too because amman
that was a whirlwind of a first four games it
is two to two it's a tied match but this has
seen kind of anything but even not by how they
played but just by the direction of the match
and alina was on the cusp of a 3-1 lead and all of
a sudden she loses on time in a plus 10 position
yeah and you mentioned you know a bit of karma
there whether you think it's that or not i think
somehow based on the chess we've seen the time
management we've seen everything we've seen so far
somehow i feel like two to two is exactly
the score that this match should be at so
we've got that two two match i think this
is going to be a very exciting one uh for
for people that maybe are just tuning in we have
uh lars oscar hough against alina catchlinskaia
and i guarantee that this is going to be a very
close one because from what we've seen alina is
capable of completely outplaying her opponent
but also completely blundering and flagging
where where nobody should should be doing that so
it's it's a tale of two very different styles here
that's certainly the case and i'm trying to figure
out who has the momentum here if you believe in
that because alina dominated that game so from the
chess player's point of view like well that's a
great game i'd rather be crushing my opponent and
just happen to lose in time but at the same time
you need to win it's a match and lars just like
i played some really not great chess in that game
and i still got the point so who does that favor
well i'll first say that lars played the move e4
and then they went to a break and they came back
and they goes d4 so he's getting in her head a
little bit there um but who's who's it actually
favoring i think that lars based on his style
um is probably really happy with how the match has
gone and um i also don't think alina is the one to
be affected by emotions uh so to say so i don't
think it'll be a negative against her but i think
lars was saying look as he pointed out i haven't
played my best chess i also missed the mate in
one first round things have kind of been up and
down but the end of the day it's 2-2 right now
if i start playing better chess and competing over
the board more i'm still gonna have you know this
natural blitz tendency this time management that
that he's been showing the entire match so far so
i think he's probably happy and if he improves
things work out sorry knight b5 sighting i saw
a rook on c1 i saw queen on c8 and i was like wait
a sec the pawn on c6 is pinned knight b5 threatens
to go knight c7 check with the fork of the king
and the rook and if you take the knight this is
a problem what yeah this is um not good and if
we just take kind of one move back for a second
yeah he takes d5 is the natural reply when there's
a rook staring down the file against the queen
but knight takes d5 had to have been played so
that you can trade off the knights so the white
knight can't get to b5 and knight d5 is not
insane either because with the bishop on f4
you know you do have that that move available and
often played it's often required a lot of the time
so knight b5 that's just a stone cold miss from
molina and sort of rare in in the opening for her
yeah and well the game isn't quite
over yet because if you play knight c7
uh the king will have to go to d8 and then
you'll take this rook on the corner and so
you'll essentially get the situation that's what
we're about to have where black will have a bishop
for rook white's pawn structure will be worse
white's king is still in the center for now
so maybe it's not the end of the world because for
rooks to dominate minor pieces you need open files
and there really aren't many of those just yet and
the rooks aren't connected in any meaningful way
so perhaps alina still has a chance in this game
yeah and i think lars is thinking about knight
takes d5 here um to take back here and say look
i'd rather win a pawn and have that happen but
knight takes d5 bishop e6 i think he's eventually
going to conclude that that's just too murky
and that's why he's going to take that rook for
sure and we get this position look she doesn't
even take the knight because the knight has
nowhere to go the b6 square the c7 square covered
this is why knights in the corner of the board
are not good simple math only two squares that
i can escape to it's not going anywhere so good
move i would say bishop d3 at some point alina
will have to go queen takes a8 and if that's the
case your queen's all the way in the corner and
now white's queen can try to make progress on the
other side of the board yeah and i wouldn't hate
this position too much if i was lena like of all
the things that you could have after knight b5
i feel like she's kind of doing as the best she
can uh she's gonna pick up that f4 pawn i think
yeah hit the rook um there is a rook that can
arrive to the e file but you know white has either
rook or knight to e2 pretty comfortably um in this
position there we go and he played 92 as you were
suggesting and then castle and he could have he
could take that pawn h7 like there are pieces
that are loose in the position and he hasn't gone
for them because knight g3 is so quick but g6 not
only covers h7 but stops knight f5 knight h5
then i can't go to e4 i think the knight on g3
is horrible and as you pointed out queen takes h7
you just start cleaning up the house there on the
king side yeah and well i like this in the sense
that he's trying to take over the open file and
now probably queen f3 is very strong because the
knight is defended and that's the problem with uh
playing g6 he thought the king was like on
g8 so used to having the king castle that you
sort of forget wait a minute my position
is ludicrous like what's going on and
you know what's interesting is we've been a
bit critical of alina for playing too slowly in
certain moments she's like too quickly right
there like there was no need to rush knight to f6
she's up plenty of time and the position was far
from over at this point in time so uh knight of
six a poor decision probably stemming from the
fact that she's been losing all game she had the
oversight early on i'm of eight or whatever it
was and so she could never really get her head
into this game that's what i would chalk this
up to yeah and it actually is um going to be a
3-2 lead for lars and he can credit that pretty
much to that knight b5 that we saw so um that
that opening trick that robert pointed out that's
at this high level that's enough to win the game
for sure and we are back to a dutch so there's
something about this that lars liked even though
we hated pretty much every step of the way for
blocks but here we see a difference e6 queen
e7 and this is a totally different dynamic and
the difference being that instead of c6 queen c7
the queen's in the center of the board the knight
comes to the center rather than over and there on
a6 so he's playing more principled chess but at
the same time we still like the situation for
white because you can play rookie one try to go up
on e4 at the moment maybe start with queen c2 to
bring the other rook over to e1 it just feels
more flexible for white yeah that's a great point
um it's also important to remember it's like yeah
uh you know we're wondering what lars liked about
this was he's repeating it it's like well i think
i know what alina liked about it maybe it was the
plus 10 or the plus 11 you know that she had last
time so she will repeat this all day i feel like
until lars proves that he has a line that does a
lot better one thing to consider before playing
e5 by black is sometimes the strange moves c6
just to take control the d5 square first and
then play e5 so i feel like c6 e5 is the better
order but of course e5 straight away is possible
and that's actually why alina played rook c1
is if e5 now knight d5 has that serious punch
because the rook is staring down the c file that
pawn on c7 so i like the way you explained that
and she's showing exactly what amanda's talking
about and here well maybe you have to play c6 or
maybe a6 just to take away the b5 square because
knight b5 surprisingly is an annoying threat in
some positions yeah absolutely imagine e5 takes
takes you remove knight b5 it like hits the pawn
and threatens bishop a3 that's exactly right well
speaking of bishop a3 she went for it because that
pawn on d6 is now tender and if you play e5 you
can no longer take back with a pawn that pawn is
pinned to the queen and by playing e5 you'd open
up the queen on d1 to that pawn d6 that would be
a humongous blunder but d5 for white is still
tempting to my eyes because i'm trying to get
to that pawn on d6 and i'm trying to take one of
your pawns c6 or e6 and get right through to it
yeah so d5 i guess my instinct would
be like e takes uh c takes and then c5
and almost try to turn it into a some sort of
fianchetto benoni or something all of a sudden
actually that is a serious idea for black
because the pawn f5 is very helpful because
typically in the bononi white's pawns are an e4
maybe an f4 you're just crushing in the center
now black is everything under control so perhaps
my move d5 i'm tunneling on this pawn on d6 and
some kind of waiting move something that can
grow the position before you force the action is
recommended alex what about your yeah your moves
that you mentioned queen d3 queen c2 you mentioned
earlier just trying to get e4 and the nice
thing about this is that black can't meet this
with e5 before that happens so um d3 by the way
probably better than c2 because it also stopped
at b5 which was maybe a potential idea yeah no
actually that's a really good point so it's just
limiting your opponent's options here so queen e3
does it all it keeps d6 under your attention you
take away the e4 square from maybe a 94 for block
and now white can play e4 herself and just all of
black's typical options not really feasible
here so what is black's move at this point
that's a good question i i'll wait for
lars to maybe show me the way here because
uh e5 not possible obviously d5 not possible c5
i would say possible and maybe interesting but
it would certainly be a move that's different than
what he's been trying to go for with his last uh
couple moves he says no anyway did you see that
she pre-moved pawn takes b5 yeah she knew that
was coming and she pre-moved the pawn takes and
then went bishop to b4 so the pawn of b5 i guess
couldn't be captured because some kind of bishop
a6 type of thing but that's why she put her bishop
on b4 real quick and bishop b7 by black if knight
takes b5 hitting the d6 pawn there might be an
inter mezzo bishop e4 and that queen is tethered
to the knight on b5 and i'm not so sure that you
can trust that uh that position there yeah all of
those positions are actually really interesting
because when you take on b5 with your knight
the d6 pawn now is under attack but you have
to really dig deep and calculate you can't just
say oh this looks good because at a certain point
it'll be finger pointing and counting like wait if
i go there my opponent goes there and so on so wow
look at that move a5 another pawn sacrifice by
lars here but you know what i don't know sorry
uh what i don't love is when you make a move as a
pawn side device and then start thinking actually
what was the plan there because you know what
white was threatening in the last position was
knight to e5 so a slower move like a6 maybe 95
happens and there's knight c6 and if you take it
pawn takes and you're using that pin so and maybe
a5 is just the necessary move and is he going to
follow it up with b4 or what's he thinking
of because i think b4 and getting the knight
involved in one of those nice central outposts
and backing it up with the other night might be
the way to go here oh of course but the question
is why did he spend 37 seconds making that because
it's not we're not trying to roast the guy but
the thing is of course that was his follow-up
but then maybe he saw a ghost and it was like
hey actually before that might not be it but
it had to be the following you played a5 to
dislodge the bishop and then b4 of course
came next so that is one of those moments
where he may regret it considering he is down
over a minute on the clock now and sometimes
what happens is you plan on playing b4
and then you calculate a line after b4 and you're
like wait maybe that's not so good and then you
take a step back you're like wait a minute
i don't have an option just play b4 and stop
thinking about it right trust yourself if i'm
going to think about if b4 is good i should uh
i should have done that before i played a5 and
right here the position is really fascinating
because the bishop on a5 is trapped look at that
knight on d5 protecting b4 covering b6 covering c7
all of that bishop's escape square so queen
to a7 if you could dart that queen to a7
the bishop is trapped so she says let me play e4
and blast the center of the board open and just
like in an attack you can distract your opponent
by opening the center okay that bishop on the on
a5 is maybe trap but if i open the center here
queen a7 there could be knight takes d6 here
there's some bish knight b6 bishop b6 one of these
moves probably saves that bishop on a5 yeah knight
b6 saves the bishop but i guess you don't have to
like i mean you don't have to obviously allow rook
a5 and drop the bishop on c8 so she's going to
start like this there is bishop takes d5 as well
followed by knight b6 wow she goes for that but
i mean there's also bishop c7 or bishop b6 but
so she's sacrificing an exchange because bishop a6
yeah just hits the queen and behinds the rook but
look at the material account what's the material
white has two extra pawns and it's almost like
having three extra pawns because the double d6 d5
situation i guess d4 is also under attack this is
a mess this is a mess i feel like it's
a mess that black should be you know on
the good side of coming out of this but um as
you mentioned a lot of pawns are going to be
falling i think take takes and just takes on d4
is probably pretty good he's gonna go for that
i would probably i don't think i would have traded
i don't like the look of that bishop staring down
my f2 pawn but perhaps she'll play bishop c5
at some point although that actually will fail
to rook takes a4 so be careful about the sun moves
that's true bishop f4 though um followed by maybe
h4 king g2 get that rook to d1 now yeah that's
a nice way to deal with this because the 984
is trapped the bishop on d4 keeps it stuck so rook
d1 perhaps is necessary and she plays it right now
you can play bishop f2 check king takes f2
and g5 you're inducing that king into a pin by
sacrificing your bishop but black doesn't have
that many pawns remaining so that could allow
true white to escape if there's one thing
that's hard to do it's win a chess game
with no pawns on the board it doesn't matter how
much material you're up you'd be surprised how
much you rely on those pawns you don't
even think about them but in your head
there's something clicking that says oh yeah and
i'll win because this will be a queen eventually
or something absolutely and so that means rookie
four is a smart move by the way rook takes d4
almost works rook d4 rook taking bishop
e5 hitting both rooks that cannot defend
each other but there's rook d one check so
maybe play king g2 and just try to be sneaky
that is very sneaky king g2 like g5 might be
tempting and then rook takes d4 as an idea yes
and she does king f1 oh you know it's a new idea
it's pawn f3 to kick the rook which is the only
defender of the bishop on d4 because king of one
looks bad after g5 all right g5 looks like it just
wins the f2 pawn by force the bishop needs to
move i take on f2 but the bishop doesn't have to
move just because it's under attack you play this
clever pawn f3 move kicked the rook out of e4 and
now the complications alina is up a minute
on the clock here 20 seconds approaching
for lars he's got to make a difficult decision
if not g5 here he's got to sack the rook on f4
yeah on g5 okay and she's going to play f3 right
yeah f3 and i think the rook just goes back
and then rook takes d4 i would not complain
at all if i had this position for white
no absolutely and i think after taking you take
with the pawn i think you leave your rook on d4
you want to hit the d-pawn your knight can rejoin
i might actually play king f2 and say take me on
g3 keep my pawns connected i don't want to lose
pawn but she does what you said and i like what
lars did quickly a rook c2 coming and try to get
a background checkmate against the king i think
you need to run your king up she does just that
yeah and get f5 and king f4 that's going to be
crucial f5 i think is super important here yeah
and that's something that's easy to miss when
you're trying to calculate a variation uh to this
extent but f5 there she played it in mind you had
it covered and now the king escapes to f4 d5 is
falling the knight will come back in the game and
you may laugh but white might win this game not
just because of the time but because the position
after rook takes d5 that knight comes into c5
maybe even to e4 and the black king isn't exactly
the safest king there is no and if you play knight
takes though keep in mind there's rook check rook
check and rook takes d4 with a outside past
h-pawn that h-pawn might be the hero in this
game because they're still winning chances
for black now that the h pawn has been taken
i think there are chances for both sides of this
point i prefer white's position the clock you have
three pawns in a night for a rook and now wait
a second i feel like they're gonna be some forks
in the near future but knight d4 should do the
trick it's so scary to to think like these rooks
are just so poorly coordinated rook h4 is an idea
yes but now the king can go to e5 thanks to that
check there so a4 played rook h4 king e5 let's
go king d5 only move literally the only move
and a5 push him yeah it's got to be a5 here
remember there's oh i don't like the look of
because the knight is very slow
you mentioned in the previous game
nice gonna say rook h1 but you don't need
to take these pawns he's getting greedy here
and he can't take him because after rook
f5 a6 your rook can't get to the pawn a6 a7
promote me i yeah i don't think he i don't think
he realized rook for he like sandwiched himself
very nicely then he sandwiched himself there
robert yeah just it just had to be broke like
h1 h2 and just get behind the pawn and run that
h-bond and hope for the best and that was a huge
mistake by him and we're back to game one in
a french but a different kind of french we now
have a tarash and the difference being that the
position is a little bit more open white's knight
on d2 may not be the best square for they can
always go to b3 and right i guess i'm still not
over that last game i'm trying to force myself
to be that professional commentator who moves on
when the next game begins but yeah that was a huge
miss by lars in that game it's true and it's it's
really exciting because every game we've seen has
had some conclusion that we haven't been able to
just go to the next game immediately it's always
something to think about and you gotta wonder
whether these players have short-term memory i
feel like they do both of them seem to be going
into that next game no problem uh whereas the time
scrambles we've seen have been seriously intense
for real and i saw lars reaction his eyes
went wide he's like what what just happened
there but in all seriousness and in reality it was
actually never clear like i wouldn't say that his
advantage was anything to speak of throughout
the entire game so maybe he overestimated his
position at points and that's how you get to
this kind of position you have a rook against
a knight so you should be better in theory but
then there are all these pawns to deal with
so i wonder if that played a part where that
material it makes you feel confident that you
should have good winner chances but in reality it
was nothing like that look at this move b5 says
hey have a free pawn snack on that my bishop's
coming to b7 that's a juicy diagonal to work with
holy smokes and that's not the first b5 pond sack
that we've seen in this match robert so both both
players are just willing to toss the pawn uh and
and say look give me the initiative that's more
what blitz is all about yeah and if you castle i
was about to say if you castle queenside if you
are alina you're happy in a sense that you don't
have the b-pawn because what do you want to do
when kings are not outside the board you want to
attack how can you attack sure you can create a
pawn storm or you can use open files and without a
b-pawn your rook comes to b8 that is an open file
to work with and it's not like the king on c1 has
that many defenders in front of it so i believe
the evaluation bar that i see on screen here white
is slightly better but it's a very tricky position
full of plenty of tactical opportunities certainly
i think king b1 is reasonable white would love to
play knight g3 hitting the queen but bishop takes
e3 is going to be a check and he can't take with
the queen because queen takes b5 so either moving
the bishop back which has happened or king b1
uh seemed reasonable there rook c8 and wow already
mounting the attack as you mentioned those open
files and look at this counter attack time pawn
and g4 comes to mind here you can have that pawn
take it your g7 pawn behind your knight that
captured g4 will be a target and i want to
point something out very quickly is that rook f
to c8 i know the rook on a8 couldn't get there
yet but we're often taught to bring our rooks to
the center of the board but alina is saying no my
attack is what i'm going for queen a5 rook b8 now
i have my three major pieces my queen and my two
rooks on the a the b and the c file and guess what
there's a king on that's going to be one soon i
imagine that's not going to be happy to see that
configuration feases yeah that's a great point
and being able to queen h5 to a5 uh completely
changes the scope of the position i mean g5 by
white is merely an attack it's it's not attack
on the knight rather not an attack on the king
i don't think that that things are going to be
as quick for for lars on the king side but if he
wants to g5 knight g4 and then try to sacrifice
the knight on f6 or h6 that might be the play
you know i was looking at some kind of fabiano
caruana style tactics with g5 and bishop takes
h7 check and just going for it and you know
sometimes you're inspired for good reasons
other times you see a great player do something
and you're like yeah i'm a pretty good player
let me try that too and like well that's why i am
not in that player's shoot because when i do it
it doesn't work but that's what i'm thinking
of maybe i can get a bishop takes h7 check
and if i get the rook lift as well that could
be a big problem so actually rook g4 is a sneaky
move at this point if i can either the knight
goes to c5 maybe there is bishop takes h7 check
rook h4 queen h5 and all this good stuff but i'm
getting that would be funny that would be crazy
yeah this is uh wishful thinking for the
attack i i think a move like your king be
one move it doesn't look as good now i know
you're not we're just at this moment because
you're walking into rook b8 and tactics on the
b file but that's where your head goes so it's
like i mean i need to move my king to safety
but no towards the corner of the board is not
safety in this position very tough position i
mean knight to g4 sort of springs to mind as
getting the uh getting the knight involved but
i i don't think that's the way you want to go
there's a lot of hanging pawns hanging checks
in the position this is tough this is very tough
both sides launching an attack i think the engine
evaluation is just not going to help anyone here
right not that they know what it is but it's
certainly not going to happen wow that is a
big decision because after bishop takes e4 now
the b file is clear it's a rook b8 threatens
queen takes b2 check with a made to follow and
the bishop is now brought in to attack the c2 pawn
if you ask me if you forced me to make a
prediction this game i think black is going to win
yep that's what it looks like right now just
because also that bishop can just go back to g6
so even if the attack doesn't work i mean you just
kind of bring the pieces to open files bring the
bishop back and you just have pressure black and
almost in a crazy world just say hey queen takes
h2 i know it looks ludicrous but give me that free
pun your your attack is nothing it doesn't scare
me hey we're all the phenol ludicrous here i mean
queen takes h2 it looks great so i'm i'm with you
there that the bishop on e4 is that powerful
of a piece it's on the longest diagonal so it
goes all the way back to a8 and then hits the
h1 corner while attacking the pawn on c2 and
defending h7 so queen f4 check by the way if king
b1 there might be bishop takes c2 or the bishop f3
is the threat so what's happening here yeah it
looks like bishop f3 you have to go like queen
no queen e3 there's rook c4 yeah so queen hack
is going on here queen of four check maybe queen
e3 to start that must be the object but then i
don't trade queens i just move my queen away to
h4 perhaps it's getting a little bit and
remember it all rook takes c4 almost works
because you wrote c2 but the queen is going to
be hitting the bishop so there's no rook takes f2
takes f4 it's kind of important to remember
that whenever there's a discovered check
make sure to first confirm whether or not you
can take the piece that's giving the check
that's a really important point because that
would look almost winning for elena but the
bishop if it were on g6 it works the bish 24
it's under attack so the queen needs to move
but queen h4 which is what i suggest before
runs into rook d4 defending the knight in
c4 and pinning the bishop on e4 i don't like
that so much so queen f5 is the only other way
to keep the attack going and knight d6 would look
scary but now rook takes c2 check is a cool move
because the knight forks the house after queen f5
96 but c2 hangs the check then i move my rook out
the way and there's another check and that
should pick up material for elimination yep
and c2 is hanging uh the knight is hanging
it looks like maybe a rook d4 kind of has to
be played you lose this pawn but sometimes
when the bishop takes in front of the queen
it's not the best coordination to have like all
of a sudden white starts to get a few tempe yeah
that's a very good point and if you could somehow
get that knight to feel defended so you don't have
to worry about it every turn white will then
establish some control over the board here
but not when you lose the c2 pawn i mean that's
a very scary pawn to drop but i'm with you that
rook d4 looks like the move that may have to
be played and what's funny is that the rook d4
and bishop c2 maybe queen e5 or something like
that is possible perhaps not queen e5 but the
point is if i trade queens there there's no pieces
on light squares so you have a discovery with a
bishop but nothing to win literally everything
would be on dark skirts that's hilarious
knight d6 also jumped out at me maybe as a
possibility on that last turn just because again
speaking of taking the discovered checker you
know that knight d6 hits the rook that's the
piece that's giving the check not the bishop
so um but there's six was definitely possible
some kind of bishop b3 queen c2 mate right like
the bishop would have moved out the way and
the queen would have landed where that bishop
came from so you know you're right that
you are attacking the checker and look look what
he did he somehow has kind of escaped but now what
i'm looking at the clock he's down a minute on
time i see the eval bar black is doing extremely
well if knight takes e5 here rook c2 check or
rook takes c1 and queen c2 mate something like
that is just devastating so e5 is a very good
move yeah i have to give elena credit the queen
can't take because f2 follows the check and the
position collapses so it's looking great for alina
and she's up a minute and 10 seconds and this
you know we've talked about this before don't
want to jinx her she needs to play confidently
and not get herself in time trouble to match
lars's clock yeah something's like rook d8
i was going to say and then remember if the
piece is exchanged and the king goes to e2 you
always have like bishop b5 just increasing the
pressure basically if alina ever gets an h5
in to have a king a safety square some luft
that that's going to be the end of the game king
on c3 this is crazy b3 next lars he doesn't care
he's got seven seconds he may as well go for it
and look at him with rookie through check oh walks
right into it but it's maybe it's not the end of
the game like after rook d3 track you have to give
your queen you get the bishop so materialist
materially speaking black is of course a head
but there could be some universe where the a7
pawn drops and all of a sudden like queen takes g5
though yeah that's that should do it because now
when you play h5 and there's no there's no g pawn
in the way so i and that the a pawns are double
there's no way to get a pass pawn i'm feeling
pretty confident here for for alina just play
h5 or something i'd feel much better about white
chins if you could put a bishop on e3 rather than
not to take the queen but just to defend more of
the border the bishop is strong in attacking one
side of the board while defending the other here
that's not happening and the a7 pawn will survive
so with that being the case alina should be able
to put this one away yeah queen c7 even or queen
d6 is better yep okay just picking everything up
how many pounds you have just two it looks like
more yeah it feels like more i i think at some
point she needs to take the i would take the
a pawn okay and it's gonna be resignation yeah
he says look just just go next go next i've had
enough of that position i had enough for that game
and when elena is is on she's really on robert
like when she wins it's a beautiful game start
to finish alina took control ever since b5 i feel
like black had the initiative and was dictating
the tempo so i mean it's really impressive when
elena puts that full game together it's more about
the clock and time management those are the areas
that she seems to suffer in sometimes i'm with you
there and we're back to the dutch in a different
version of the dutch because the bishop's on e7
rather than on g7 so it's just interesting
that even when we have the same starting moves
we get a unique position and here we see e4 we
talked about this the first time we saw the dash
you blast open the center and guess what black's
pieces are quite passive here look at the bishop
on c8 bishop on e7 and the pawn on e6 is going to
be a long-term target if you take on e4 that's not
exactly pleasant for block to deal with yeah and
even though you can toss in the move knight b4
white's just going to retreat the queen e2 and
take back all the same on on e4 but this is a
natural freeing move but i don't think that it's
necessarily the the worst thing for black to allow
i mentioned some sometimes taking everything on e4
is exactly what uh the dutch player needs to free
the pieces like sometimes you you take everything
and there's some sort of knight b4 followed by d5
give your knight that d5 square you give up the e5
square but you get a square for yourself so knight
before is going to be played and we'll have to
see what the follow-up is because i think it's
got to be taking and some sort of e5 or d5 break
in the center to gain some space e5 hard to play
once you remove the knife from c6 because
it might just drop a pawn and oh wow okay so
bishop f5 is the idea so tactics everywhere
i'm with you now i underestimated this i was
i was thinking about the material but bishop
f5 getting the c2 the d3 square under control
that is actually pretty scary and when he played
that move he he sat back like he he it's almost
like that that move had some kickback to it like
as soon as he played it he's he started rocking
back in the chair and he is is ready for the
tactical skirmish that's about to occur here
and it's about even the clock this is what happens
in these long time control games i was thinking
that we'd be down to a minute left per player and
then i look and they still have four minutes left
i'm like oh wait they actually do have time to
think because we just went right from a finish
where there's not much time to all of a sudden
okay let's breathe let's figure this out so
now that we're trying to do that can i take on
e5 knowing that bishop f5 is coming she does
that but where's her queen going is she going to
take on b7 as well no she sits on wait knight c2
with a fork queen c2 queen d5 check king h8 is
is sort of the expected variation there and then
is it going to be something aggressive like
you know getting the bishop out or is it
really going to be that that rook you want
because rook b1 looks like night before back
and you just lose a full rook yeah this uh this
doesn't look ideal but we've seen her play an
exchange down before i think she wants to take on
d6 and if bishop takes then like bishop g5 with
tempo and then she would get a rook out safely
okay and what if you take with the queen on d6
oh didn't quite get to that one and we don't
need to it's okay we don't just exactly
like that line didn't exist we had it covered so
now the e5 pawn at the very least black should be
able to make a draw on those variations of knight
c2 move the knight back away and the rook on b1
will be hanging so that's why she played bishop
g5 but i'm kind of concerned she's playing more
for a loss than a win and it feels like black's
pieces are perfectly situated the rook on d8
can go down to d2 at some point soon the bishop
on f5 is doing great the knight on b4 is excellent
so isn't black better and the evil bar seems to
indicate as much um yeah here even like i think
maybe you have a choice between h6 c6 all those
kind of moves seem pretty decent h694 rook d4
might just be a good way to get doubled with tempo
and and yeah even though there's an isolated bond
there you have to look at the piece activity black
is enjoying an open d file an open f file um as we
see in room d4 played and yeah it's knight c5 i
think just b6 or c pawn will be loose after that
all right take c4 where does the knight plan
to go well b6 rook takes c4 there could be a3
and some bishop d5 check so you have to be careful
if you're large before you take that pawn on c4
as uh there will be that check on the
diagonal and picking up the rook so
that's a good point i think i would start with
this and then reevaluate throughout c4 because b6
is under attack right now and after b6 there's
no there's nowhere dangerous that the knight
seemingly can go i yeah and i did not like this
move because now if knight takes b7 the knight is
safe over there a5 is hanging and i want to keep
my a pawn i want to take on a5 and then promote
that a pawn thanks to the bishop on g2 oh g2 long
range although i i just caught myself because
bishop d3 is a threat for black trying to win
the f2 pawn so it looks like there's that outside
past pawn that will go well for you but black has
the initiative right now and you need to watch out
for mission d3 yeah bishop d3 is the idea knight
i guess knight d3 could be played here but i have
to admit that that is a pretty brilliant move and
the main purpose of that is to fill the d3 square
yet knight d3 looks menacing hits b2 hits f2 but
much scarier was bishop d3 to dislodge the rook's
defense and so you're willing to give up b2 you're
not willing to give f2 and if knight takes b2 now
perhaps just rook to c1 try to trade off a pair
of rooks and again the a3 pawn wants to dart down
the board with the help of those minor pieces yeah
and now i mean not playing d6 from lars is maybe
just trying to keep the position too tactical
because he had a positional approach there b6
solidify secure those bonds and then go forward
against white's weaknesses but here it's like
everything is just getting treated left right
and center we've talked about discovered checks
a lot this match knight takes up two everybody
takes and there's no good check again that's right
you know another example of that and if that's the
case and the pawn f2 isn't directly under attack
i was gonna say can you push the b pawn and the
f2 pawn though this is so rich this position
losing f2 the end of the world or is it just
hey if you take on f2 you're also sort of stuck
because i would like to trade one pair of rooks
from white's perspective because then your attack
won't checkmate me and black would love to put
that rook on f8 down on d2 or on b2 whatever
and take on f2 you want to mow down the seventh
rank but that's not happening so i think that
you're okay giving up that pawn even if it's not
preferable and then that a3 pawn watch out for it
yeah it's almost like if the knight could take
on f2 and you could sort of get this e pawn
going that would be ideal but it's not it's
not that easy to do because i mean the rook
stops this pawn very easily and remember these
rooks are not both on the on the second ring
right so there's no discovered checks there's
nothing like this in fact they're not really
coordinated that well at all actually i like a
little knight journey here for white knight d4
the rook moves to d2 then knight to e6 the rook
moves to defending the knight on f2 the knight f4
blocking the rook's defense of that knight and
hitting the bishop on g6 so this could actually
turn south very quickly for lars here yeah yeah
that's a great point i think you have to choose f6
because you have to defend this bishop otherwise
it might even just be losing a piece after
right and now i think that elena has a choice the
c7 pawn was hanging but she plays knight f4 and
now look at this knight d5 the pawn moved opening
the bishops defense of the d5 square hitting the
rook hitting the e3 pawn rookie six defends the
pawn or well can i still capture it because the
knight on f2 loses defender this is just great
night hopping yeah this is beautiful alina she
played it on a dime too she had that whole pattern
that whole uh root mapped out she was ready for
e3 knight d5 boom and it's like this knight on f2
it looks so menacing but she's unfazed it's right
beside her king there's some threats but she says
look it doesn't matter i've been moving one piece
the last four moves and exposing the lack of
coordination in black skin and look at the last uh
moves 24 through 28 these last five moves knight
b3 knight d4 96 knight four knight d5 that knight
came from a5 and then just said hey i'm gonna
go three squares over there to d5 that took
a long journey but she did it with tempo after
tempo and now the final tempo is just so powerful
hitting this rook on f6 this pawn on e3 white is
winning material and then that a3 pawn can finally
shine and the bishop is open all the way down to
the edge of the board yeah and this this is crunch
time for for lars there's 97 there's knight e3
sorts of good moves here yeah get rid of that pawn
immediately and by the way the 93 protects the
bishop on g2 so even if black is somehow able
to throw that rook on f8 down on b2 the knight
covers the bishop so it's not even a huge threat
at the moment so just move the rook to e1 i like
defending the knight king h-shape and now a4 a5 a6
a7 question is why does this not just win that's
basically what she's asking yourself right now
but don't ask for too much longer because exactly
we've seen this before remember this is actually
gonna be the last game right of the the five
minute portion so if she goes in to the break with
a two-game lead that'll be the first i think the
first two game lead of the match would be super
super important yeah she could have had a 3-1
lead remember she lost on time in the fourth game
heading into the break so this would be the
first two game lead of the match you're correct
and well look at that knight on g4 rook
coming down to f2 this is starting to
look a bit uncomfortable so she needs to find it
several accurate moves and if she's able to then
she should have the huge advantage so whatever i
assume the knight's gonna go back yeah i was also
thinking if could you bring that rook down to f2
from f8 and try to checkmate along the second rank
yeah i think for now with 14 seconds he's maybe
going to repeat and and use the time that alina
is spending to think because he knows i think that
alina wants to play for the win here that's been
the case you know that's the direction the game
has been going but time ticking down we've seen
lars excel in these situations and looks like
she's willing to repeat moves he's thinking he
he's trying to play for win perhaps because he
hasn't moved it there it is you cannot take on
g4 well you can but after a move like bishop
takes f1 you cannot take back on f1 because
that's your typical checkmate with rook g2 rook
h2 okay what's happening here bishop is getting
so dicey bishop g6 oh wait the bishop was hanging
i thought it was mate for white all of a sudden
bishop could be captured okay so rook f2
okay you need to save your king and now
rookie eight and the pawn is just trying to run
now alina is not worried about like getting mated
or losing this game because she's done a good
job containing the rooks i think brook c2 and
great move yeah she's going to be up a pawn here
should be a draw but um she's she's done a great
job so as much as uh as she can and only she has
the winning chances here although with the time
the way it is oh rook b2 maybe and yeah brookie
2 g5 g4 you're kind of trying to check me at the
white king a little scary there after the game
i would like to highlight that rook c2 moment oh
what oh my gosh yeah that would have turned things
around real quick h4 shotgun wait h4 put the king
in the game and put the king in a meeting net oh
no she could like lose this now yep we cannot wait
to analyze this though she could lose this after
king h3 rook check oh my gosh oh it came back
the rookie jade chad was a threat h3 h3 that
wins king g3 and then king takes yes take
and then just your king moves out king f6 and
then the rook check is a threat to get a queen
yes like my gosh run run run that's
gg yep and now brook g8 anywhere yeah
i'm sorry excuse me not anywhere that's true
that's true actually that there's the only
square the rock could move in the game it was like
anywhere oh yeah just the only move on the board
rook anywhere obviously oh well let's just
analyze very quickly a couple of those moments
uh if you don't mind we can go back to the
moment rook c2 and i think that that was a
really instructive moment because i think most
of us are so focused on our a3 and b4 pawns
that we we tunnel we're like oh my pawns are under
attack but the problem is you're going to lose one
of these pawns regardless a3 is under attack and
if you play rook f3 then rook takes b4 happens
and your a8 rook isn't defended so you
are losing a pawn by force on that from
those two uh files so she plays rooksy two
giving up one pawn to go up upon up ending
and then i mean as we go forward from there i'm
on you could take the wheel because there was like
a checkmating net for white and also for black
it was wise this was i mean the evaluation bar
is is just going up and down all over the place
so rook v8 was the first i would call a pretty
serious mistake because i think you should
just throw an h3 check kick that king back
um and the reason is that black can throw in the
check here this is what robert and i were both
gasping at because you always want to check
uh and force your king your opponent's king
back where possible so rook jack the king would
have to go back somewhere here and then king h3
there's never going to be any checks to that
king and if you're not careful all of a sudden
you might be losing both of these pawns as white
and maybe get into some trouble so that was miss
and then b7 so now whenever whenever the pawn is
there robert it's all about hey can this rook ever
move anywhere with a check because that'll always
be winning right and then when rook b4 was played
which was a big mistake h4 check is beautiful and
the point is if you go to f6 or h6 i simply give
you a check and then my pawn promotes with the
defense of the rook i go up a rook and if you go
king to g4 because that's the only other move that
doesn't allow a check it's the only move rook f8
and if you take the pawn there's rook f4 checkmate
the king is ensnared in a mating net and there's
nothing black can do to avoid it because the best
you can do is give up your rook for that pawn
to avoid the mate but i don't even think you're
getting that far just really beautiful stuff there
and i you know i saw it i had the idea in my head
but then the eval ball went and i was like okay
it has to be h4 and the mating net there is just
devastating that's that's like a one you might
find in puzzle rush absolutely yeah and uh but
yeah that that that game was just wild that was
probably the biggest miss um that we saw there in
that one and robert it's it's gonna be that two
point lead as we go into the break from the five
minute portion i mean what are your thoughts on
the match we've seen so far because every game it
feels like the time scrambles uh that we're seeing
are so intense every single time for sure and
i think if you're alina kitchen you have to be
very happy that you just won a game in a time
scramble because in the back of your head in
a match with this kind of format you're thinking
bullet section bullet section even if i'm up three
games on the match score what if i'm the underdog
and my opponent just wins all those bullet games
but now you just prove to yourself and everybody
watching that you can win a time scramble and
you're not just going to make mistakes and fall
apart so that's great she's up two games lars
he's right in the thick of this this is not that
big of a deal she has to be the favor at this
point in my opinion but he is the favorite bullet
player and as we get to three minute amman i feel
like his chances should start improving with the
quicker time patrols yeah though that's going to
be the next that uh stage as we have the three
plus one portion of this match the players are
gonna take a break as they get set for that and
robert and i are gonna do the exact same thing
so everybody calm down and we'll be right
back with the next portion after the break
and while we're in the midst of an enthralling
match we should let everybody know that there
is another great event coming up starting in
february it is the pogchamps 3 presented by grip
six it's going to be another great event featuring
celebrities and popular streamers you see here
in the graphic in front of you you have xqc
returning for a third time bloodwick makes
his reappearance after starring as a commentator
moist critical and we have a lot of first-timers
here mr beast myth rayne wilson yeah you're better
known as dwight schrute huh pokemane code miko and
daniel negrono the poker legend michelle carey and
of course logic who is a fantastic rapper and also
an avid chess player so amman any early favorites
from your perspective or anyone you're kind of
rooting for or just curious to see how they do
well i think it's great that you got some of the
favorites returning uh to the pogchamps tournament
but then you also have tons and tons of new people
um joining up i know logic has been streaming a
lot of chess lately um i think that it's gonna be
interesting to watch the sort of outside twitch uh
participants such as rayne wilson such as daniel
negranu um such as logic take on people who are
more comfortable on twitch and have been streaming
a long time like myth pokemane and all those
streamers that we know so i think that's going
to be the most exciting thing to watch who's
going to do better robert it's the mini game
is it the twitchers or is it the people outside
twitch so i'll be looking forward to that it's
a great question and what we're all looking
forward to is the next part of this match
it is three minute plus a one second increment
time control elena casting sky leads five to three
and we're off as soon as we start talking about
the games have begun alina gets the black pieces
again and amman the question that i'm wondering is
what is largest first move going to be we're back
to a french yeah and he wants to give this one
another go um there's no reason why he shouldn't
be interested in that and he's already switched
the variation up or uh i should say maybe alina
did no i think elena played um bishop b4 last time
so it was alina who changed the variation she did
and that's what happens when you are watching
players of this caliber and for everyone who's
tuning in why do they keep changing their openings
is there something they don't like they're capable
of playing many different lines and that keeps
their opponents on their toes look at this b6 then
g3 let's have a stare down the bishops with the
knight in the way and if we quickly show bishop b7
bishop g2 f5 it looks like wait that knight
can't move you lose the bishop on g2 but it
can move with check and that's why alina starts
with pawn f5 so she can be first the diagonal
yeah and something seems a bit off here if i if i
can just say that the f5 knight back bishop b7 and
does white have to play f3 you could potentially
d5 and sacrifice a pawn that is somewhat
thematic but f3 was played and that i don't like
this looks bad all right this is not good um
there's almost like ideas like knight
c6 where bishop f6 hitting the pawn
knight e2 is not possible and then if you castle
there's an idea of bishop to g5 pinning the queen
and if f4 you already pick up that rook in the
corner such a good point the castling queen side
just could lose in exchange right away for and
i think that's the idea oh that's nice i need to
pick that pawn up and castle bishop g5 is a real
idea wow uh so that doesn't look good so what
it's a rook d1 played yeah so there we go we're
already seeing the weirdness that this position is
yeah this doesn't look great for white and look
at this because white's position has taken so much
time just to get here elina castles and that may
seem like she's walking into a potential attack
but she has the bishop pair and the bishop on
f6 is unopposed and going to make use of these
dark squares and i love the idea of queen c7 or
queen c8 here uh not trading and instead keeping
the position tactical i think the dark squares for
white the only option being castle and king's side
are insanely weak so queen c7 i was a fan of i
also like that and well she's playing quickly she
is slightly ahead on the clock here she's bringing
her night out she's fully developed and i didn't
like the move castle by the way i think king f2
was more precise we're in an end game so your
king should be closer to the center now it's not a
pure end game there's still some attacking chances
but king f2 looked better to me than castling
right yeah because i mean maybe you want to
play king e1 at some point maybe the king goes to
f1 but f2 it would already be defending that pawn
i can i can basically agree with you uh simply
based on that robert imagine the king on f2 it'd
just be better placed and we're probably going
to see that in the near future the king coming to
f2 and look at this knight f3 check a possibility
that wouldn't have been allowed had the king been
on f2 now black has the pair of bishops but let
me ask you something here what can those bishops
attack the knights are defending each other so
can white just try to trade off the rooks and
say your bishops are kind of useless yeah i think
i think in general the the bishops should be a bit
better in the same game but knights are so tricky
in blitz and i completely agree with the idea
of just trading everything off there and alina
agrees as well because she says no that's not
gonna that's not gonna fly here bishop c6 the you
know the d file is yours but rook d6 maybe rook c8
kick that rook out immediately and and then
regroup and bring the king towards the center
this is a great lesson in knowing what pieces to
trade and both uh you know iman and i were kind
of hinting at this you do not want to trade all
the rooks off alina says yeah i agree let's keep
a rook on because now this rook can poke and prod
rook v8 hits the b2 pawn maybe can jump into the
b4 square and cause some problems for white and
as though white is the first the punch on the d
file that rook is going to be kicked out and then
the king can walk to the center and look for h5h4
on the other wing and this rook on c8
will be valuable as the game continues
and i think that black might consider a move
like c4 at some point because i was going to
say with that pawn on a2 if white got c4 that
would be ideal for his position but now that we
see bishop b6 with c4 coming i'm really liking
the way lena is treating the bishop pair here
agree it again and c4 there is b4 for white you
do not want to take that pawn on c4 because the
rook on c8 was like hello good to see you here
and we'll win that one right back so i think
that white needs to keep the position closed there
but look at her playing on both sides of the board
guess what bishops outclass knights when they're
pawns on both sides and for in the future f6
e5 let's get a pass pawn right down the center
yeah love the way that she's playing here black is
just so much better there's h4 there's c4 now c4
there's no b4 move which you pointed out because
a4 is hanging so it could be time to get that
movement and yeah she's focused on the king side
right now and she wants to take on g3 play rook
h8 get the rook down the line uh there because the
bishop one c6 covers the whole diagonal and she's
i just love the way she's doing this it feels like
white is just struggling to even come
up with an idea here and the bishops are
promising and looking in all directions yeah
that's that's like that's a grimace for me not
like the look of c3 just the rook on v8 it doesn't
matter if it works now works later that is gonna
hurt uh white's position eventually yep and
knight c4 bishop c7 you probably have to do
something like knight c1 or rook to b2 but either
way f6 or bishop d5 those are the moves that come
to my mind here and how can white continue h8 too
is a way to get all the way around the position
because the g3 pawn that's why h5 h4 was played
by alina g3 is this the soft point now rather
than h2 which couldn't have been attacked
so rook g1 for instance will force that king
to f2 but then maybe there's rook g2 check so
actually after actually one how do you defend g3
yeah beats me uh rook g1 looks quite strong here
um i mean c5 is hanging let's not forget but
after you play knight c5 i'm not too sure
what the follow-up is right so knight e5
that sounds about safer than bishop e yeah they
say well now bishop d5 is better because there's
no c4 to kick the bishop out and oh can you wait
rookie seven no oh my god what it's still there
oh my gosh and that's how a great position turns
into a horrible one just losing sight of the
d7 square oh my goodness b3 is hanging there's
going to be endless checks here by the way wait
that that was completely unexpected i
understand how this happens in a blitz game but
white's up a piece was there no way out
no you had to go to g1 and then play knight f1
no i'm trying to think how do you get out of that
wait sorry don't you just go to g1 h2h3
we can we can show uh on the analysis
board real quick while these next that's
like that was weird couldn't you also
yeah that's so strange what happens if you go
all the way here i i don't know oh over h1 so so
knight f1 which is what you said before is
good because the knight e5 yeah let's read
about f6 though or the knight c4 back to d2 or
something like that ah that's good that's good
yeah he's not much time though he didn't have much
time and honestly that was the weirdest kind of
draw but it just sort of happened well this game
should not be a draw by the way that one happened
look at this position where we we just tuned back
in yeah bishop takes g6 and just checkmate in the
next few moves by the time we figured out why
that one was maybe drawn it this one's almost
over by checkmate so we gotta be careful these
three minute games are going so much quicker than
the five minute portion and bishop g6 knight
d5 is in the position the queen to the h file
i mean this has to be a good attack and simply
knight takes d5 queen e6 check you can just move
your knight back to e3 so you can steal that pawn
and oh you could even go you could even go knight
e2 almost with like some bishop h7 trickery i
don't think it quite works but i wanna i want your
queen to take on d5 and then i have some bishop
h7 checks but right doesn't look like it's quite
so working does go for it yes or she does
go for it yeah she takes and now 93 back and
well she's what's the material i haven't even
looked black only has three pawns left and white
currently has five so two extra pawns but that's
not the important part of the story it's that the
king on g8 lacks defenders and after knight back
to e3 white's next one will be knight to f3 and
likely knight to g5 and good luck to your king
on g8 yeah it's a hilarious position there's just
no point i talked about winning a game without any
puns well black on move 16 has already given up
five of them and this is the kind of thing you
need to do if you're large is somehow get some
counter attack going you're looking like you're
getting checkmated on the king side can you try
to muster up some counter play i i don't see it
just knight g5 yeah knight g5 and i'm wondering
where this queen ends up getting to queen e5 queen
ah maybe yeah queen e5 there's no actual follow-up
i want to get my queen into the game for white but
i don't see a wave four then i don't have six is
covering everything yep so maybe we start with
bishop f5 actually where's your queen going yeah
it looks like f seven and then knight g5 bad
knight g5 and then bishop b6 that's game over
oh that's game over oh my goodness and it was
a process of elimination thing here and she
plays bishop five this is you're winning
the question this is the type of moment
where alina's style of being so calculated and so
precise is exactly what just wins her the game on
the spot here she's not playing knight g5 on
a whim she's saying look how do i absolutely
crush this position bishop f5 she realized is
forcing bishop e6 and that is completely over
just as straightforward as he gets and
we tuned in sort of late to the game
but as soon as we first looked we see okay it
came from this kind of banco gambit black is down
some material but normally there is a result you
getting checkmated in the first 20 moves in fact
black is the one who's supposed to be attacking
because you give up pawns for quick initiative
yikes this is and how do you think
he's going to continue playing because
it's either resign or you got to sack your queen
for like the best amount of material possible
it's one of those moments where you just give
up and yeah the variation itself is one that
is extremely dangerous because white just pushes
all her pawns forward and that's what happened
and we're back to here bishop f6 gfc okay he's
not going to play g3 this time there's no way
no you're right you're right no way that did not
work out for him last time not even a little bit
and here it's another example of throwing in the
check which is meant by an easy block and then
retreating the bishop because you closed down the
diagonal look at this the bishop comes to f3 just
like it was trying to go to on g2 except now you
don't have to create problems on your king side so
your bishops is nice and calmly here still though
black can play f5 bishop f6 and i think this is a
good position for black and i can't believe i'm
saying about that again about a french on move
12. i know it's uh it's blasphemous but uh the
position is is solid because c5 is gonna happen
at the right moment f5 is always there long castle
looks solid i feel like f5 followed by c5 is
really gonna be a good position for for alina yeah
and there's so many tactics as well knight to e5
for black the rook on d8 says i'm willing to stare
down with the queen all the way there on d2 and
so there's a retreat 95 still speaks to me where's
your bishop going maybe okay she says team b8
still 95 still there 95 bishop e4 there's like
f5 to follow up knight c4 or knight g4 in that
position finally we do see your move robert you're
getting some credit around here i'm feeling good
about it and now c5 feels powerful if the bishop
leaves the f3 square the only square you can go to
is h5 which puts some pressure on the f7 pawn but
the knight e5 it protects it so it's not a threat
right there and i think you play c5 and open all
your pieces up although c5 is a bit dangerous
because if black does play c5 there'll be knight
b5 ideas for white so just because we've been
focused on it doesn't mean that you necessarily
have to go for it and i would refrain at least for
the time being from playing the move c6 to c5 yeah
it looks strange but bishop h5 is probably exactly
what white needs to do in this position and queen
e3 just just feels like it has to be wrong right
queen d3 might run into bishop a6 problems
for that queen there and queen c1 speaking
having to be wrong putting the queen back on c1
and look at lars you saw that he just grabbed
his head threw his hair all over the place and now
he's like uh so when do i when's it my turn when
do i get to start pushing you back yeah exactly
he's in uh full full focus mode because i mean i
know it looks crazy but you know i'm looking
at queen takes h2 i'm just letting you know
i'm checking it out i actually was thinking the
same thing as soon as you move a piece you think
what has changed well the rook was defending h2
and elena puts her king on a8 so what is her idea
why is she putting your king all the way in the
corner there's never going to be some kind of
like you know rook usage on that side of the board
like rook b8 doesn't add to the position at all so
i don't really fully grasp what she's been doing
and yet i still think her position is totally good
yeah absolutely like knight 92 i understand what
lars is trying to do he's just trying to trade
things off like if these knights disappear and he
gets c3 in maybe g3 um long term that h pawn over
there is something to worry about in an end game
and if you ever play c5 i don't think that he's
going to be too upset trading those light square
bishops and getting rid of the bishop pair for
alina so i understand what he's doing he's saying
look let's trade pieces because i don't have a
lot of space and this is really going to help me
uh finally get to move and he takes up the rook
he didn't want to walk into any sort of pins and
bishop g5 was a threat so what rook d3 was played
and lars is well ahead on the clock here and queen
h6 could come at any moment so it's now all of a
sudden the dynamic has changed completely queen h6
is what i would play here saying my queen sitting
on c1 not doing all that much but he sits on
e3 instead yeah i think he can throw in g3
at the right moment to sort of solidify everything
also knight c1 to b3 to c5 was an idea and maybe
what what prompted elena to play a5 say look
a4 i'm going to control all these queen side
squares you can't use them right and i still like
the queen going to h6 but perhaps okay rook d2 i
i'm trying to grasp what like the idea hit here is
and one of the ideas i'm thinking about for white
is playing rook c1 c3 but you didn't need to make
those last few movies of g3 and rook back to d2 so
i guess that's not what's going to happen but i'm
just looking at that c6 pawn as a potential target
what do you think of c4 here and then knight
takes c3 with the idea knight a4 to knight c5
anyways king a1 was played so oh i think it he did
want to do it but he wants to take with the pawn
okay well that does make some sense although the
b file doesn't look like a disaster i wouldn't
recommend opening it it feels it gives white too
much play and easy play and look at the clock
situation lars is well ahead on time so i would
not want to make his life easy so bishop a6 hits
the c pawn if c5 thank you for all of the light
squares your opponent d4 is permanently at target
so i think that well what do you what do you
do here really for rook c1 i guess but i don't
like that either well c5 and like i don't
know knight f4 next or something play c1
knight c1 doesn't feel like the right one no i'll
put it that way and i like this move bishop c4 a
lot saying that knight wants to get into the game
no and i can play bishop d5 and look at your pawn
on d4 i am stopping that pawn's progress entirely
and i'm going to pile all my pieces and try to win
it later knight takes e2 though and suddenly
that pawn is very well defended and like rook
d5 there's always knight f4 right so the cranking
off to b5 it's just slithering into the position
yep what is queen h6 going to happen or is it
never going to happen it might just never happen
but now it seems like a great opportunity to just
throw it in there right because just like h2 was
hanging in white's camp before h7 maybe can be
captured depending on how the game gets used this
he wants to plant the knight on b3 just some
stable square which i totally understand
knight b3 covered by the pawn guards d4 and then
maybe he's comfortable finally playing queen h6
yeah i like this much more
now watch out for that c6 pawn
so she's just sort of moving she's
playing quickly she's ahead in time now
and i do not like f4 i really don't like them it
locks in your queen so there's no counter shot
okay and they each have you know 20 seconds ish
a piece there's pressure on d4 but honestly this
is a tough position to break break through like
maybe you run the king all the way to the king
side or something and switch the rooks okay well
she's starting with the the rooks and then i like
your idea king d7 king e8 run over there so
queen f3 at least gives the idea of queen h5
at the right moment but i would start running
that king towards the kingston like you said
yeah oh okay maybe she's noticed that
queen on e2 hit the queen on b5 i feel
like she didn't notice that is the king about
to walk in kingdom oh my gosh yeah it is and
rook a8 i almost want to play king e4 there by the
way but h5 we're waiting for this h5h4 by the way
king c4 talk about unnecessary king
moves but she's protecting the pawn on b4
and and you can tell lars wants to play this
position he doesn't want to drop yeah but i think
he's worse and i see the evaluation part says
as much check okay and rook b5 c7 all ideas so
winning the b pawns losing the c pawns but now
the d4 pawn stays and look at the king look at
that king oh here it comes king e4 king f3 oh no
this is a nightmare king i actually have no idea
who's better here yeah i think i'd rather be black
it just seems trickier for white to deal with this
king d1 oh bishop b4 was a mistake rook a6 to
cement the pawn on the dark score was better
that's a great point yeah now the light square
pawn is is safe rook b3 is the idea of a king e4
is fine oh look at that clever move shutting
the rook off so you can win the pawn on a6
and king's oh knight c1 to b3 oh king c2 can't be
right no that way he should be fixed now he's lost
bishop takes d4 and king king of three
blonders the bishop don't play king f3
wait the knight's just trapped f6
then it's completely stuck there's no and
then e4 is going to win that when the knight
is completely stuck so oh my gosh wait it's the
wrong h-pawn so if you could somehow yeah usually
you have no way to do it but you just had to get
in there and point out it was the wrong h-button
wrong color h you never know when that will uh
make its presence felt so uh it seems like we
are actually getting a break right midway
through the time patrol the players get to
take a step back think about what's happened
and i think alina is going to be happy because
she has won two more games to take a four
game lead so mon before we go on break
any sort of thoughts on what lars
can do to right the ship here
yeah can we talk about uh that for a sec like hang
on isn't alina undefeated lars has to um go back
and really recalibrate in this uh three minute
portion so i'm really excited when we come back
to see if he's gonna change anything because it's
just not working at all for him right now robert
it really isn't even when he's up on time things
still are going to lead his way she's kind of
outplaying him so all credit to her we will
be back shortly for more three minute plus one
second action from this i'm not a gm specialist
championship match brought to you by chess.com
and we returned alina kashminskaya has opened
up a four game lead over lars oscar hogg amman
it's really tough sledding out there for lars and
during the break we're kind of joking around but
how does he right the ship how does he correct
the mistakes he's been making does he need to
play a different opening which he seems to be
doing every game or what i don't know well the
some of the openings in particular that i felt
have not been going his way especially the the new
french line i think he needs to examine that uh
because the the line that elena is now going for
where getting these double pawns and playing
b6 i think it's really working out for her so
i would stay away from that line um going into the
rest of this three-minute portion and especially
in the bullet it's gonna be more pronounced if
you really don't have a clue what to do so i
would stay away from that i think that the dutch
is still very viable he's been going for that but
as i say that he decides to switch that up and
is it going to be a grenfell king's indian it
looks like he's going for kings indian as he comes
out of the break with again something brand new
zero surprise that he's going for an aggressive
opening and the king's indian if you look at it
from this point of view the bishop on g7 is stuck
behind some pawns but it gives you chances to open
up the board later and this g4 line is one that
says f5 good luck making that work because i'll
take with my g pawn and then my rook will come
to g1 and your bishop on g7 will be pinned to
the king so this is just a way to clamp down the
position i think very smart choice by elena and
uh i mean i might need some brushing up on
my theory here but knight b6 looks like a uh
extremely peculiar move especially because often
times when you play this the idea is hey you make
white play b3 sometimes that weakens the diagonal
it's not what you want to play but white was going
to go knight e2 knight g3 no matter what and that
b6 just i mean it looks really misplaced to me
it is very misplaced and black's best move is
pawn e5 back to e6 right you need to open up
this position it opens up your bishop but also
allows you to start chiseling towards the center
knight c5 good for you it attacks nothing h4 says
i'm going to play h5 i'm going to play bishop h6
i'm going to trade darts for bishops and i'm
just going to checkmate you on the king side i
have no idea what lars is playing here because
there's there's not even a b5 in the position
a4 threatens nothing f5 is just non-existent
because white's just going to take everything
and you can't give up your light squares like
that so it's just like oh this is so bad robert no
yeah it hurts to kind of look at here but is the
idea to go king f7 and run the king somehow is is
there a way to king f7 rook h8 bring your other
rook over and then run but the problem is there's
also a timely bishop takes c5 to then play d6 six
six oh and that bishop robert is not playing chess
for the rest of this game you mark no no and then
you can take on c5 and play d6 and just open up
the center because you're playing a piece down is
black your bishop is caught uh in the corner and i
would probably go for something like that it's not
necessary and that's why alina is not doing that
but i mean what does black do here it's it's so
bad because i think what she's going to go for
is the more maybe traditional approach b3 a3 king
b2 b4 maybe bring this knight to e3 bring a knight
to f5 and she's just going to take her time and
she knows this is an absolutely crushing position
yes one of these positions and we often suggest
it's the good thing to do is what is your
opponent's plan if they had a couple free moves
not just take all the pieces but what actual plan
that isn't just relying on an opponent's
mistake and black does not have any plans here
because your pieces are all stuck the e4 and
g4 pawns mean that f5 is impossible and if f5
is impossible your pieces over there that
are just lumped together on the king side
doing absolutely nothing so if i'm going to talk
about a plan knight g6 knight h4 queen takes h6
okay trying to snag that pawn and just go back
and at least free your yourself over here and a4
played because b4 c5 is so crushing that he says
look i know i might lose this pawn at some point
it's quite possible like bishop c5 bishop c2 queen
d1 but i'd rather play a4 get that in follow up
with b6 and you know just just see what happens
and another thematic idea for white is to think
about knight to b5 and say you can take my knight
over there but once i take with the c pawn my rook
is happy my rook can go to c4 the a4 pawn is the
target here and while she goes for the exact thing
you were talking about queen back to d1 can you
play queen e8 and yeah defend there i was thinking
about queen eight i guess here you sort of have to
decide are you going to go knight h4 and focus on
liberating your bishop which is what has happened
or are you going to go queen eight and focus on
trying to keep the queen's side closed i guess one
of the major issues that if queenie was played the
knight f5 happens and your bishop is just frozen
the bishop on d7 you can take on f5 but then
you'll lose a4 eventually so there was no choice
you were losing this a4 pawn and i like this
all things considered just i'm going to try to
win h6 so yeah i would take on c5 i think and then
take on a4 and just i don't care about the h pawn
but she's too strong knight f5 she's too strong
just too strong she takes and remember if pawn
takes uh from the g file there is definitely a
world where you know there's like a sack on g5
to meet the the black king sacks on g5 second h4
the king is bottled up over there right she sticks
with the e pawn so she wants to take on c5 and
then put her knight on e4 at some point exactly
that's just that's just a beautiful positional
way to play whereas you and i were both like
let's go for checkmate why not where's the maid
so if you move the knight knight takes f3 becomes
a possibility for black because the bishop and a4
need defense that's why she wisely retreats her
bishop and look at this knight g2 i like that move
yeah so i mean say what you want but i think that
lars's position has actually improved and um i
don't believe what 92 is there maybe even to go to
d4 rather than take the rook right that's what i
was actually looking at yeah this is not so bad he
gets h6 and rook slides over i mean he's holding
especially when time travel ensues i mean there's
no knockout and that's the big problem is once you
play h6 it looks horrible that bishop one g7 is a
pawn but it's a good pawn you're protecting this
is what dania says often and is an expression bad
bishops defend good pawns and that pawn h6 will
save your king the pawn in f6 keeps everything
together e5 and g5 so it isn't that horrible yeah
at the right moment bishop f8 maybe h5 and rook h7
i like h5 rook h7 slide the queen over and bishop
d6 and you you complete your building blocks over
here but i really think h5 just got to go for
something like that maybe rook h7 to preface it oh
king h8 i don't like putting your king to make h5
more difficult i'm not a fan of him okay knight
takes d5 so that is probably what kha was played
yeah there are no pins there's no queen b3 pin
can we make use of it at least uh the king h8
move and go knight d5 what's wrong with that
i think that elena will say you know what i'll
take it and open the board up your bishop one f8
still stinks so look at this she trades rooks off
and says hey how's that bishop feel it's it's not
an h8 anymore but it's not that much better on f8
right i think you take and go h5 yeah take
this and go h5 like i think you just need to
wait knight takes off six knight f6 that's queen
a4 a queen b3 as a response that's an important
pawn but this is also good for kf7 though oh
wait so you can't go queen in because queen a4
check yep yep there's going to be queen c6 as well
lurking in the position king g7 once that happens
anything goes here queen b5 is how
black gets involved oh look at that
is knight g3 knight h5 coming
does that just i like queen b3
queen b3 looks good rook d1 so wow does rook d7
because in queenie two check there's knight d2
so that knights are excellent defenders against
queen checks very often king's going to safety
rook takes c7 i say with no cop what the queen's
covering oh my gosh oh my gosh now black is just
a head and that's a queen exchange and rook f7
to follow or rook takes c6 yeah oh my gosh you
know if you lost the c pawn there would be some
chances for white to hold because the h pawn's
the wrong bishop g7 and it's it's over f6 rook f6
the rook is trapped the rook is completely tracked
it went from black's bishop being trapped on
h8 robert by a pawn on h6 defended by the rook
on h1 to the rook on h1 being trapped by the
bishop from h8 that is just terrible karma
yeah that is ridiculous i mean that doesn't
make any sense whatsoever but you have to give
lars so much credit for fighting until the
very end this dude does not go down without
clawing his way back into any sort of counter play
like he just even the smallest bit of counter play
he latches on to and he flagged the lino one game
and he just won that game where i mean frankly he
didn't really have any business taking that full
point nope absolutely none that was incredible
that game was like plus four from the
opening without any material imbalance
robert that that's incredible not only was there
no imbalance not a single piece had been traded
oh my gosh and well look at this game alina is
up a pawn right now because lars sacrificed one
and i'm not sure i'm buying it i feel like this
was a questionable decision out of the opening
already for lars i see the evil bar off the side
says minus one but sometimes minus one positions
are very difficult for black to play i don't
really have the sense that this is that hard
for black to move forward in yeah i was gonna say
you sort of have to decide um between moving this
e pawn or not like you can try to develop around
it but she says look i don't see any issue with
this sometimes the problem with this is bishop
d5 check and taking on e6 but in this position
there's always queen a5 picking up that bishop
potentially yeah and there's gonna be a check but
i think you can just block it and then uh here you
go queen a5 check and there's no knight c3 which
there usually is in positions with where you have
this tact such a good point that the knight is
not on the board to help you out here but bishop
c4 so if you take on d5 queen takes d5 stares in
both directions at f7 and the b7 pawn and e4 as
well so in three directions that's not good so
taking is not going to be played probably oh queen
f6 i was in queen b6 but queen f6 is way stronger
hitting b2 hitting f4 protecting e6 and he says i
do not care about b2 but yeah see overlooking b5
yes it did the bishop's trapped bishops just
tried you take on e6 it's actually is it just
pawn takes that yes it looks weird but take
away that d5 square yep and i was going to
recommend e5 first from black to then go b5
because that way your king wouldn't look less safe
but this works you're just winning a piece and
i suppose i don't think lars can believe it look
at his face right now he's just kind of like um
is this really yes it's really trapped right now
and he was the one going for tricks and yet
he gets tricked because that bishop stuck
and it's funny because he sacked
that pawn on e4 but it's that pawn
which is making the bishop trapped it's a hero
you know not the one that maybe alina deserved
but the one she needed in this game it just keeps
that bishop locked in and this is resignable
yeah it is it's getting we talk about you know
that plus four that elena had in the last game
no material imbalance this is minus four
because there's gonna be a material imbalance
and i'll say that this is some evidence of having
good nerves for elena because in the last game
she was really just cruising to a victory she
lost but then she bounces back it's a weird
opening that you don't see every day and yet she's
handled it perfectly finding moves like b5 and
this is just the position she's up
a piece and should not fear at all
absolutely knowing myself i would probably play
e3 here because i'm scared i'm with you and it's
funny i'm on because you and i talked about this
before the show even started we're just you know
hanging out and chatting like sometimes we give
too much respect to our opponents where we see
a potential attack we're like no no no i'm just
gonna close things down and i think e3 was a great
move but perhaps it wasn't even necessary at that
point but i i like it i would have played the same
safe and all the pieces are coming up remember you
can't castle without blundering that bishop on d7
uh no doubt she's conscious of that rook d8
is a move that comes to mind knight e4 is
obviously what lars is up to here hitting the
pawn sort of eyeing that that d6 square but
um i think there's there's a lot of reasons why
that's not the end of the world yeah and knight
d4 is saying i'm not going to hang that bishop
and i'm going to close down the d file it does
make sense but white's next one will be c3 the c5
pawn is hanging there's actually some chance here
for lars and now they're heading towards a
minute and less and lars already below a minute
but this is where mistakes happen right
except three checks at the rep by the way
that's a nice one so c3 just knight takes f3
handles that because otherwise c3 looks so
logical here yeah that's important knight takes
f3 and that's why bishop takes was played but you
have to think here you have to rook d8 the king
is going to get castled and that's the magic thing
as soon as the castling happens you feel like
alina is out of the water although white now has
two pawns for the piece so it's not as clear as it
felt several moves ago the bishop on d7 is hanging
behind that the bishop on e7 is hanging and look
at this move queen eight that is the move that
was needed to keep everything tied together take
on d6 move your bishop away from d7 start trading
some pieces you are up a minor piece for just a
couple pawns oh she goes out there wow brave move
yeah absolutely knight b7 would make me a
bit concerned okay yeah she just has full
confidence look at that queen went from e8 to
b5 but not directly he went back to h5 and then
to b4 that's clever so impressive to to come
up with this because this is a better version
than giving up the bishop for the night but she
comes up with this like it's you know clockwork
i'm very impressed by it by that maneuver for sure
and lars brings his queen back to e3 bishop's seat
finally at long last we can start training pieces
and now your extra piece makes his presence felt
absolutely bishop to maybe a6 or b7
takes rook d3s who is in the position
i like that bishop b4 okay watch out for some
kind of knight f6 check though right not now yeah
but some kind of knight f6 to shatter your pawn
structure try to get checks against the king not
too many pieces defending that black king doesn't
look like it's under attack but it could be
yeah that's a good point rook c7 is always going
to fail to queen d1 check although bishop d3 is
knight f2 oh no this is getting funky oh no that's
a pin and 15 seconds oh gosh not again that's what
she's thinking right now because only a three game
lead seven seconds taking down robert oh my gosh
and takes on d3 queen e6 that's what i was
wondering do you throw a queen e6 check here
yes and there's queen e4 right very important
not queenie hake is the queen of a4 covers but
this check take on d3 oh my gosh lars is not his
favorite yeah but he's well on his way looks very
winning well queen if i want a brave move what a
good move i might add okay we see a repetition h4
where's the win here king h3 g3 maybe
something like that okay queen d3
queen c2 queen d3 looks good with the queen h1
check and take on e5 at some point black can
likely take that knight and try to hold that but
you get queen e2 maybe it's me oh it's wait queen
x5 queen h5 won the night oh my god queen jack
would have won the night and she lost in time
she lost some time oh it hurts so bad it hurts
robert there were chances for both sides to win
that yeah of course up a piece from the opening
can we talk about the resilience from lars i know
we were crediting the technique from alina but
he turned an opening blunder of one entire piece
at the international master level into a game
that was not only competitive but that he was
even favorite to win so this is just incredible
and if you're alina now i was saying you know
her nerves are great but now your nerves might be
afraid and you're just angry because you have been
winning several games in a row now you're still
up two so you should take some solos in that fact
but i would be fuming at this point just like how
can i not beat this guy i'm up a full piece and
the game before that the bishop was trapped in
h8 and yet that bishop beat me so oh frustration
so many things that if there's one thing that
i truly believe is in elena's favor right now
it is you know short-term um memory loss like i
don't think she is thinking the way that you and i
are probably thinking that she's like you know
reflecting on the last game i don't know like
you're saying she might be rattled i don't think
she's that kind of player and you know that's
just to her credit if she can always focus on the
next game but you just have to feel at some point
everybody is uh is susceptible to that for sure
and she actually has another very good position
i'll say that much because wait the pawn d4
you take that then d5 the position opens up
which way is your king going neither side is safe
so lars knight 65 right three pawn f you know f6
i was trying to go f6 and e5 but somehow lars
figured this out he said i will lose a pawn but
then d4 is hanging at the end that's actually
not that bad yeah what clever guy very clever
lars is you know he's he's uh always combing his
hair back as if he's about to put it in like a top
knot or something but it's like just short enough
that it's not possible but it's long enough that
he constantly has to comb it so very relatable
things robert as we get into the world of you
know hair and grooming and all that and elena
is locked in right now i mean you look at her
she it's what happens to all of us when we're
playing on camera at first we think okay this
is the position i'm going to be in the entire time
and then you start slipping you start slipping and
you're like next thing you know your forehead's
right against the camera because you're staring
so intently at the computer screen and wait a
second couldn't she have moved her bishop out
of the way first and then uncorked a discovered
attack with a rook on d1 and that queen on d6
definitely yes i think there would have had to
have been like some sort of queen e5 move or
something like that because i agree if the
bishop moved there was just knight b6 check
i still like the position for white i would play
f4 here and then try to play e5 i know it cost me
my f5 pawn but i don't really care about that
one so i would i think i'd play f4 e5 for white
yep the the worry here is that if there's no
immediate crush for white i think black is just
better with the with the bishops especially
in an end game so i like that four movie it
you know pushes the tempo yeah and gtx 5 is
a very difficult move to play knowing that
e5 is coming and it ruins your pawn structure as
black but e5 is happening whether you like it or
not and so you just have to accept that fact
and it's played so the question is now where
do you put that queen queen e6 is the greedy
way to play try to hang on to that pawn but
knight g3 says no that's not happening this
starting to look quite nice again for white
uh so i'm trying to think long term here isn't
this knight just better than the bishop for
now but the pawn on f4 perhaps could be a target
later or in the fact that bishop b6 covers g1 well
not anymore but that could have been useful if
black ever was able to seize control with rook g8
i don't know a3 like that move just taking the
time out um because look what happened queen
c8 brook takes d7 it's almost like you got a
free a3 move in there and that's so so useful
i agree with you there and that just make sure
that the king won't fall victim to some kind of
background checkmate but i still don't know how
white proceeds from here and i'm looking at that
h7 pawn and thinking well is the rook on egg kind
of tied down because if it moves then my queen
will open up an attack over there but i don't see
a useful knight move right now knight d6 of course
comes to mind but maybe then that allows the queen
to go into g4 or something like well speaking of
queen g4 yeah it's possible now hitting the knight
hitting the pawn rook g8 knight e4 and h6 but
knight c5 there knight c5 was excellent she was
focused on that f6 square but knight c5 going
queen b3 threading checkmates throwing knight
d7 check all that stuff wow i'm with you there
is it time for i was going to say a6 wait no 97
knight d7 you can't go king b7 because knight c5
b5 was a blunder yeah and he knows he's blundered
yeah that was a that was a big slip i mean bishop
d8 literally forced here but there is going to
be some sort of check made on the board knight
b6 pawn takes queen d8 rook d7 and i think
you see that one as well but she did not
and i see the evaluation bug go down because queen
f5 check and then rook d3 the only way to survive
oh my goodness knight b6 was like just screaming
knight f6 is actually a major blunder here if he
finds queen f5 not played and elena remains
in control yes because the bishop is still
stuck back there the black king is open and the
h-pawn is now a passer yeah queen f5 and rook d3
is tough tough to spot very and you know i really
i always admit this i quickly looked over i saw
that the evaluation bar shrunk and what in the
world could it possibly how could this be equal
you need some kind of counter so i thought queen
of five checked but like that didn't do anything
could be some wild move queen b3
hits the rook as well with rook g2
yeah he does go for rook a3 this is very
interesting yeah you would love to move your
queen out the way and get a new queen but queen
a2 check is happening this is scary for alina
yeah this has really been been blundered it's
quite possible white loses this game as well
look at the evaluation bar it just oh queen f5 oh
quinn i mean queen f5 is so so nasty with rook a1
and he he knows he's got the win here okay one of
those queen takes f4 it all looks good for black
yes and this is going to be the third game in a
row where lars oscar hogg looked like he was dead
lost he had nothing going for him but he fights
to the very end and he is going to take this game
unbelievable stuff frankly i think you just
take that rook let the queen happen regroup
and then uh you know start brook f1 rook d3 in
the checks from there yeah rook f one king two e4
queenie two i mean there has to be a i think
you just ladder just ladder the whole way
across the board yeah queen g2 rugged one just
yeah there's speaking a lot meeting two and wow
and we still with time for one more game and i
feel like that is not good news for alina because
she probably could use a break right about now
losing three straight games and lars once again
goes for some kind of offbeat opening here oh
and you know what this one is this is this the
ortho snap or something that's what it says i i
didn't know what it was called but i see french
defense steiner ortho schnapp gambit and i'm
like does that mean i'm gonna about to get my
teeth fixed and this is what's happening here
yes this this is the one that i i mean i think
uh jonathan schrantz uh had the video on this
first i know that eric rosen has some videos on
this but i can't remember who did it first anyways
both of those guys love making videos on super
creative openings and the idea is exactly this you
just play knight f3 castle knight c3 and look at
the insane amount of development and compensation
it's just a very fun way to play so i'm really
excited we're seeing this in the match yeah you
know it rivals only the drum gambit in terms of
it just just uniqueness and just it's allure so
here black is up two pawns but the king is in the
center f7 is under attack how does black castle
you're not going to be able to castle are you no
basically the the answer is no uh i think
that after d3 taking it already invites a
tough position i think i think lars is extremely
happy with what he's got he's almost pre-moving
rookie one if not for d2 or something but this
looks incredibly good for white and i think rookie
won king f8 knight c3 or or bishop g5 i mean he
is doing very well here yeah the the really bad
news for elena is that she's cleared out the
pieces in between her king and a rook on the
king side but now she's had to move her king
and the queen side remains underdeveloped so
bishop takes f6 may seem too scary to allow
but i think you just have to and then your
king gets the g7 square to run so i i think all
things considered knight c6 was a good choice
and if i'm lars i want to just play like knight
c3 rook a d1 get all my pieces in but knight a5 is
currently an idea for lena and yeah i think knight
a5 he's i guess gonna meet it with queen takes d3
yeah i guess yeah whatever you know i'm getting
one pawn back and i still have the initiative
there might be queen c3 and bishop f6 though oh i
thought he was throwing in bishop f6 he could have
but he said that let's just do this i like
that idea though bishop takes f6 for sure
because now there's going to be a great tactic c6
knight d6 queen he said bishop e7 check that is
beauty so sick and i think i think that she was
planning on playing c6 and now has to rethink
things because she maybe noticed this at the
last second the pin there and the fork there
yeah it's one of those situations where you want
to think what changes with every single move well
in that case the d6 square wasn't covered the
queen was loose so you just need to remove the
piece in between the queens that were staring each
other down now that you played f6 and c6 the e6
square is weaker that's where white would like to
take advantage of but you have a bishop on c8 so
i feel like alina is a couple moves away from
finishing her development coordinating her pieces
and i'm not trying to claim she has an advantage
necessarily but king f7 comes to mind right now
and doesn't look as bad yeah i'm i'm looking at
bishop g3 to get rid of that bishop and threaten
95. i like that keep in mind if you move the rook
i know people have not been taking h7 pawns this
match robert but queen takes h7 95 check 90 95
game over we mentioned that tactic and now it's
happened without sacrifice as necessary that's
going to be game over and that's going to be the
end of the portion and look at the difference it
was like 3-0 like from alina 4-0 i think before
the break and all of a sudden it's come back and
look at this it's a tied match what the heck is
going on robert yeah she was up four games and
now lars has given me some like joel kinnaman
vibes because he's just killing it right now and
she just can't handle it i mean every single game
with the exception of this last one she's had an
advantage and yet he's come back in one so i'm
going to ask you before we go to break what can
alina do to correct what's happening here because
she's losing her lead yeah i'm trying to think
what exactly lars did differently um from the
break that has caused him to get all these wins
but honestly it's just been uh tenacity like he
hasn't gotten the best position so this game was
an outlier i think this was a fantastic game but
in general he hasn't gotten the best positions but
he's so tenacious he stays in there even wondering
a full piece in the opening i think that his key
right now is play fast take those slightly worse
positions and then you know stay in the game and
his time scrambling we got to give him some credit
there so alina great chess um and just slows
down at the end we'll have to see if if she can
right the ship in bullet because we know that
she is incredibly strong in the bullet portion
despite being slow in earlier formats for
sure and one player who has accomplished a
lot despite being the underdog was teddy coleman
in the last year's edition so we'll see if alina
can just you know make sure that her nerves
don't get the best of her we'll be right back
shortly and we'll come back to the bullet portion
of this i'm not gm speed chest championship match
we just like to remind everybody that
season six of arena kings is underway
it has already begun and the events are on mondays
and fridays it's a lot of fun you can play against
people in your rating range and also maybe have
the chance to play against the likes of hikar
nakamura ali raza fruja alexander kasenyuk and the
one and only prophet danya naraditsky aman and i
you know both enjoy those tournaments maybe you
can beat up on us as well but i'm on here we're
focused on nothing except for the one plus one the
bullet portion of this match it is all tied up the
momentum has certainly swung lars oscar hogg's way
elena kashlinskaya what in the world can she do as
she's the underdog and she must be frustrated
after those last four games yeah i guess the
break was kind of well timed before it got really
out of hand because it's very easy to lose one two
three four and especially going into bullet when
you're on a losing streak it can really be like 10
games in a row just like that so i think a break
before the bullet is important uh she can look at
these tricky openings that lars has been playing
and say look i don't want to go into these in
bullet imagine defending this position robert in a
bullet game that would just be insanity you can't
be going into those let's see if she's changed
things up and is really uh basically conscious
about what opening she's going for and lars we can
see he's played bullet before because look at what
he's doing he looks like me out there because
this is what i play no matter what uh i play
the hippo style you get your bishop staring at the
center the knights in the center of the board here
but look at alina she's keeping pace and that
is essential she has a better position and she's
doing well on the clock so c5 d5 i think e5 is
going to be played and will we see that bishop end
up trapped by its own pawns again it looks like
it that dark sword bishop not very happy yeah this
is a great game so the thing is a lot of times a
player let's say such as elena who generally gets
low on time what you'll see is that in a bullet
game they just go in with a mindset hey we can't
take time in this format not acceptable and all
of a sudden they start to trust their instincts
and you realize as you're watching them wait she
has really good instincts she should do this more
often she's actually looking really comfortable
in this bullet portion which is why i was saying
keep that in mind going into it so right here
we see a great position for elena but typical
fashion lars is messing things up yeah he is he's
just mixing it up here he opens up the b-file he
sacrifices a pawn queen takes b5 the queen come to
c6 that's important as if the d-file is open opens
up the d6 pawn is under attack but i think that
lars should be very happy at this point and he
goes queen a7 there's a look at taking d6 i would
say oh that's a really nice tactical shot so that
would give her a quick attack on black's king and
i think c4 here why not c4 c3 even like it like
it takes and you know playing rook a8 rook b8 you
can't can't say that's going to be too bad as well
bishop c1 rook a8 will be it as you said and
then okay rook b3 was i like that move that's
and knight a5 there's even b4 to consider oh good
eye by you there and actually the king can go to
c2 and it's not 100 safe but it's not getting
checkmated yeah it's pretty reasonable actually
and by the way alina is up on the clock you don't
take on d5 because queen c4 would have pinned the
knight instead we well how does he get that pawn
back he wants this and queen a2 checked okay
kingston then queen c2 though yeah alina is doing
great here you have to trade queens because after
queen before rook b1 the knight of b6 is under
attack but then queen c4 and then take the
knight yeah i think i think queen f1 was let's say
overestimated because everything is protected yeah
he's got to take that pawn but this can't work out
no she can just play king e1 the knight e4 is very
powerful it blocks that queen's accent diagonal
you can play f3 if you need to and queen b3 trying
to she sees queen b3 that's so so important have
to trade d5 gonna be attempted here but knight c3
and there we go that's the rook you see him laugh
and then he laughed and then looked upset i don't
even know how he's feeling right now yeah
it's hard to say now with the white pieces
he is opening with e4 he's opening with e4 he's
just that just a happy chap there on the cam um
do you think he's going to be repeating that
opening with black or is that an experiment
you know for game one of bullet and and you
might adjust it going forward well it seems
like he's been watching me stream and that's a big
mistake because i always say there's a disclaimer
do as i say not as i do and that opening is
bad i think he should not go back to it but
i wouldn't be surprised if he does just because
he's used to that and especially for players who
play a lot of hyper bullet you're just used to
going but there's increment here it's not pure
bullet alina is playing very quickly in this game
as well but i like oh wait i liked let me take it
back i liked lars's position until he hung the
d4 pawn yeah there's got to be f6 now it's the
only move followed by queen h4 something like
that like to just make things a little bit spicy
right but if the queen's where there's knight f5
oh it's a 93 oh my gosh what robert you're leading
them astray my bad my bad um maybe this isn't
the end of the world of bishop bishop g5 now it
is the uh that's the end of the world yeah yeah
okay i'm just gonna stop talking yeah so every
everything you've said so far unfortunately has
been heated advice but um no all jokes aside this
was it you know this is bullet totally different
game robert that f6 move it might not work in you
know the time controls we've seen before but whoa
rook e4 right back in the game is alina and that's
a large type of situation you're down a piece
but you still keep your head on wait that's it
yeah knight takes f5 the f6 pawn is what you want
to get out if you could take that the
king is stuck on h8 checkmate but b4
i don't think knight h6 was the right move just
bishop d4 keep the pressure but taygo knight takes
up sick oh then c takes b2 what a nice take b2
and wow i think that's what was overlooked by lars
because it looked like you're getting two rooks
for a queen the king on aj didn't look very safe
but look at this you don't even have rook b6 which
would have pinned the knight because the a7 pawn
the a7 pawn is the hero i like rook b7 uh oh he's
trying to pin it but it's just not working hang
on what's what's the move here queen seat shoe
i guess whoa i don't like giving him that pawn
no this this one's not this hang on okay black
can't win this game now oh knight g3 yeah but
even if you lose a rook for the night it's still
going to be drunk that's true knight f2 you can
play wait wait knight of two there might be some
kind of smothered mate almost like yep queen b6
coming soon be careful uh oh rook g3 super careful
although okay and rookie three where's the king
goes h8 it's working fake me wait how do you get
out of this it's over you don't what's game over
world this game has been both players for the
taking and now finally lars should just pick
off that night white wins this game for sure or
you know this game goes ages and ages and ages
so it seems like it should just be a win for white
you can just slowly build up rook f3 because you
can trade two rooks for the queen and it should
be winning not a fan of g3 though there are some
positions where you give up the queen for the
two rooks and still make a draw because of it
depending on where the pawns are so king of chicks
this looks scary there could be some stalemates
wait queen sack somewhere watch out
for three stage four queen explorer
greece whatever give your queen away yeah
yeah there it is and then queen two queen h2
yeah exactly well actually she can waste some time
if she wants i don't know if that's part of the
plan oh my gosh yeah this is at least a draw now
for sure yes and she can let lara try to play on
for win and then you know there could be something
she can play queen g2 anytime she wants and it's
wrong and this is why you always need to be
careful about how many squares your opponent's
king has because lars was trying to checkmate the
king and it would have been checked me if he could
land a check but it wasn't lena's turn she said
let me give my way my queen no more moves for me
and it's actually kind of funny that alina played
that whole game to the end without giving up
the queen for nothing you know what i mean like
the chess player in me the the beautician in me
has to give up my entire queen at the end to make
the draw but she's just checking as if it doesn't
exist right whereas we know that she saw it for
sure for sure and well she gets the white pieces
again lars spent some time in the opening which is
strange honestly in a second move he spent a lot
of time so that's not good for bullet chest you
do get the increment he can bounce back from that
but it's one of these positions where alina proved
like she knows what she's doing and i think she
you know she just feels comfortable the opening
in this match whoa do not like c5 at all
yeah not a fan contrarily i love the apon push
because the knight gets into b5 long term hits
the a7 pawn it's just something you always have to
worry about right and the only downside could be
is if the queens and the rooks get traded then
your a6 pawn can be picked off but you're not
going to trade all these pieces there's too much
left on the board and the bishops stare down black
doesn't really want to take and allow the queen
into f5 so it's going to continue i like the idea
of getting rid of that bishop which makes knight
b5 just sting that little bit more um in general
right and take it with the pawn on d4
that's interesting i wasn't expecting that
why do you oh because if she took the knight then
she would have double her pawns in the g file i
also don't mind you know taking those squares i
agree it's not what i would first think of but
now that it's happened i don't think it's the
worst and now it looks like a french defense
right and here comes the queen to g6
and watch out for the king safety and
knight b5 so white is playing on
both sides of the board knight b5
may just win material at any moment to get the
c7 square and queen g6 of course is natural
so there's knight f5 ideas just sort of looming
mm-hmm there's rook c1 rook c2 now the rook can go
to g3 if the knight goes out the way uh queen d3
i was gonna say hang on almost lost a knight there
right so she's repeating i'm he doesn't want
him he never wants to repeat yeah just just
no he is the type of player it seems that he's
playing for a win every single game without fail
there's still nothing i see like 92 knight f4
to try to bring more pieces but i don't see
any threat lars is just jumping
around the board taking the pawns
he's doing a good job and knight f4 knight
g6 that's an idea for sure yeah and how to
follow well i didn't like knight e5 i like sitting
tonight on g6 and keeping it there knight b5 into
d6 may as well you know interesting that maybe if
it was not played it also threatened the a7 pawn
now knight b5 for sure broke c2 ooh quick counter
shot great find there yeah that's a problem
rook takes b2 yeah and a7 rook a2 so knight d6 was
played and two pawns down isalina she does have
good chances just because it feels like the king
on h7 isn't completely safe but knight takes e5
that is just that's beautiful yeah nicely done and
look at all these white pieces on the last rank
careful for rook check and knight f3 mate there
it is double check which is me knight g4 knight of
three good find by you great find by lars really
well done by him in that game and now it's a tied
match once more yeah and this is so exciting i
i don't think that i've had the pleasure of uh
commentating match yet that we knew going into the
bullet and has been proven in the bullet format
to be neck and neck going to the finish this might
be decided robert by like a single game with time
expiring yeah we still do have just under 14
minutes left plenty of time for the players
even if they drop a game here but you don't want
to be down the scoreboard and right now lina goes
back to this french lara says don't mind if i do i
just was crushing you before i blundered my bishop
one before yeah and it's the same exact line
and i don't think he will play queen e1 anymore
yeah it's one of those things where your move
wasn't so good but it resulted in something
great so unfortunately you have to switch it up
not then right and rook c8 played makes sense
still no queen e1 because the d4 pawn is hanging
that sacrifice is possible with f6 at any moment
but you have to be certain otherwise you actually
open up the board for black's pieces and that
will backfire yeah and you can't get bishop d2 or
anything like queen d3 maybe for bishop d2 i feel
like you want a complete development but maybe
h3 i would almost just play waiting he plays it
again that's hilarious i just don't believe in
it so let's pause for a second knight f5 was not
a good move knight five is also not necessary
but their knight is under attack so look at her
so many moves knight g4 okay understandable so he
wants to just play pawn takes pawn it looks like
so how about now rook g8 you just
take pawn takes pawn wait so pawn
takes pawn and knight g5 oh gosh that
was the whole plan knight g5 is killer
it's too much to work out in a bullet game
oh my goodness he's gonna play queenie one
non-stop robert it's working it is working
it's working like a charm but it shouldn't work
and i feel convinced you know because the threat
was pawn takes f6 maybe some kind of like rook
c4 move i've been thinking about this pinning
that knight so that you can take back on f6
something like that it just doesn't feel like it
should be enough for white you're only attacking
with a couple pieces so if alina is able to figure
that out then she will turn this to her advantage
but right now this is lars the game i think
you can yeah i was going to say knight g5 um
is just waiting to happen knight g5 takes
and like rook takes f7 also looks pretty good
yeah rook f7 is a threat and queen takes
g8 oh queen take g a new queen that hurts
that really hurts yeah and f7 is hanging
as well so this will probably be resigns
there it is and lars he's making these attacks
work robert he's he's getting you know he's
mixing things up he's getting spicy positions
that objectively as soon as he plays queen e1
you see that eval bar just what is this i think
it was a mouse slip i think he wanted f5 he's like
okay okay it makes sense yeah now he plays f5
because you don't win a game take the lead and
then do this you are either down four points
and are just tilted or you're up a ton and do
whatever that was definitely a mouse lift
yeah it's not that bad it's not that bad
now because the knight gets to f5 and it's
actually like very okay wow i wish i could
make mouse slips like that and not have to pay
any sort of price yeah yeah what the what the
heck just happened i don't know how that worked
out but i saw the the webcam when lars played f6
and he gave the face like ah that was a mouse flip
so i think it was but he can't be complaining here
although where's his king going
because bishop d3 the g6 pawn is weak
so he plays 97 he's gonna try to castle queenside
that takes way too much time though i feel like
yeah he's swinging bishop c6 queen d7 and well
he's actually or queen d6 he's actually going
to get it but then c5 before b take c4 take
c4 okay yeah oh wait ticking c4 would be good
yep look at this though the rook on h2 will swing
over to the queen side and help with the attack
uh-oh oh no no not again not again take me eyes
but not me bishop no that bishop on eight is just
oh gosh is he gonna win another game
with a basket piece that doesn't exist
i he he could because a5 if you take on
passant you lose the c6 pawn and well
if you don't take no no she's not taking
that she's not taking that yeah oh my gosh
i mean black's not even worse anymore is
black look better what oh gosh okay then g fun
e3 hello gosh oh no oh my goodness maybe knight
c3 to e4 he's giving peace odds yeah which gives
her a chance actually as this game continues
whoa no that pawn's important oh my goodness
that pawn's real important oh oh queen e5 queen e5
hurts rick f8 queen actually doesn't have a mating
threat yet though but queen f5 check picks up the
bishop but queen a1 just king z2 immediately i i
would resign asap doesn't even cover how quickly
i resign you needed six queen g6 and brook g8
i'm not mistaken to mom wouldn't you resign
too just you need to get the next game going
uh i probably wouldn't resign this because
i would rationalize that materials even
because there's a bit of money i see the
evaluation bar it's not that bad for white
how is this possible this is what i wanted
if you put the rook on g8 and then you just
bring the knight in bring the knight oh my
gosh if you can bring that knight over there
like 1997. he's exactly 97 is winning
so a 96 knight c2 knight before 96.
oh my god he's winning for white oh no bishop
d4 no but then just take the pawn and then
you have don't judge the bishop don't
take the bishop don't take the mission
don't take it she's not taking it that's beautiful
oh my gosh she's not taking the bishop and she
didn't resign and it's paying off wait you should
yeah she's not taking anything she's winning
oh my goodness oh my what the hell is going
on here yeah what is happening wait black's
getting out of this wait no down the road oh my
gosh she hung the rook wait a minute we've seen
this before she literally lost a rook to the
bishop that was trapped that's the second time
this match that the trapped bishop has somehow
come out of nowhere robert had taken her brook
that is what the hell that's just devastating and
we have this line that i don't understand again
i can't breathe i'm seriously impaired god oh my
gosh this hurts okay let's talk about one thing
positive in the alina camp she looked at this line
a thousand percent yes she's playing a very good
i would say close to refutation queen e7 queen
before check and she is so ready for this i can
tell that she looked at this after the break
from the three minutes yeah and now she's up
a pawn and there's no attack and it's white's
king that's being attacked bishop f5 will just
win next move and the knight before yeah yeah
uh okay this is looking fantastic so how to win
this game it feels like there's a win in like
two moves yeah a4 looks quite good as well um
bars and pieces on in the corner robert
bishop's knights it doesn't matter with him
yeah he's just i don't even know how to explain it
but he's throwing those pieces left and right and
take and rook d4 oh c6 b5 the bishop is trapped
now b5 rook takes d3 and then rook d8 something
like that i feel like this is a reasonable
move but maybe is there g4 no not quite
no king c1 that's a good move just avoiding the
pin yep and now f3 f3 looks good you can't take
on c5 because your knight gets pinned so unless
i don't think you can although maybe you can
c5 and like i guess there's back rank issues
though yeah now although blacks have a pawn
i think you'd agree knight c6 yeah you got to be
so careful here tactics rook takes d5 oh 97 check
rook deep oh my god 87 checked first oh it had
to be rook c8 there yeah no alina she needs to
resign now she needs to resign now i agree because
you're going to be down three points you need to
start the final game before the clock hits zero so
if you win two games here she will have a chance
to come back so of course has to be a very very
quick win here from uh from alina like not winning
that game is so bad uh for the match because
that was that was the the position that was like
she she did her homework she came prepared
for that same line that lara's brought to
the table and not winning that game has got to
hurt her mental she she has to win like a very
quick game right now yeah and lars goes on these
streaks remember he was down four points then
he won four in a row then he lost an early bullet
game and now he's won three or four in a row even
like losing track of the numbers but yeah now his
position he has a monster center with these three
pawns here and now they're going forward so the
way this can backfire is if white can open up the
board and that's a good way bishop c4 check kind
of ideas well actually knight 64 queen d5 check is
possible as well but the point is that the king on
j8 isn't actually that safe over there mm-hmm just
take that and some sort of shack or maybe an id4
to e4 i love knight dd4 protects the e3 pawn hits
the g4 knight hits the d6 bishop this literally
hits everything in the position and she didn't
oh oh queen takes g2 there's issue e6 check to
throw in perhaps and then rook f1 kind of thing uh
yeah i'm not a wait queen g2
queen g2 rook f1 e4 d6 hangs but
white's king is in big trouble yeah knight
b4 by the way tonight c2 or knight d3 is also
pretty crushing queen f2 queen f2 game over rook
d8 or queen takes g1 ouch ouch that might be the
dagger right there uh you know three minutes
left in this match more or less i think it's
pretty much impossible that alina makes a comeback
now robert no and i mean what a comeback from lars
down four points looking like everything is going
alina's way and then he just goes on a winning
spree and doesn't stop because he went from minus
four to plus four that's an eight point swing and
it's a weird match because if you told me just
by looking at the games that somebody is winning
this match by four points i don't think i would
think it was lars yeah yeah like it you you'd
assume that eventually all the good positions that
alina was getting all match would would you know
finally result in it going in her direction and
g5 is going to be taken no calculation needed and
this rook e3 queen h6 this is over this has got
to be over yeah and now it's just you know adding
insult to injury at this point just you're
already wounded you've lost this match that
was going your way and now your king is blasted
open on move 15. this is resignable basically
rook g3 check um knight takes e5
you can just take that back first
yeah nothing to do here it's queen g5
check this is one of those moments where
okay this match can end now this is it
feels like it's time i'm over this yep
and time takes down but there's just
no resources here unfortunately g5
um she kind of forgot i guess
that the queen was on d2 um
often the queen is not on d2 it's on e2 but
that's an easy sacrifice to make rook g3
that's gonna be it yep might get one more game
here yeah we do get one more so probably not
another game that alina wants to play but
there's still time left in the clock and we have
a budapest so that's always fun and that has been
a good thing in this match we've seen a different
opening most games and this is tricky white is
up a pawn but black has quick play and now the
e5 pawn is under attack but she seems to know this
queen d5 is the principal move well it's not like
principle it's the good move but it's hard to play
to bring your queen out into the center like this
and uh d6 played i think usually they go f6 there
but d6 looks a little bit worse uh to my eyes
white's just gonna finish that development and uh
kind of looks looks super solid here actually for
for alina right and it's sort of in a sense
kind of like an orthoschnat reversed where
it's an extra pawn for white but the black is
really going full steam ahead trying to create
some play but you're not in time i don't think
no bishop d3 looks super strong and a3 even here
yeah just not dealing with knight b4 um g5 is
usually what black wants to throw in but now
i'm not sure it works because you're actually in
a pin right and i will add that bishop a5 by black
was a really clever move trying to get knight
b4 hope that you're not looking for it but of
course a3 was the easy response and now white's up
a pawn you've castled you should be able to take
advantage here but you also don't have that
much time and the match is officially over after
the scheme and reposition maybe not that bad for
black because of white's double isolated sea fonts
yeah knight e5 b6 and you can you can sort of
play around the the extra pawn that alina has
which is pretty much the whole point of this
opening so it's very very in line with what
to expect and it went from tactical to incredibly
positional yeah i didn't think the game would take
this turn here but now c4 falls and black must
be thrilled about the position uh the a3 pawn
hangs with a fork and let's just say alina will
be not disappointed to get get out of this match
yes when it rains this point it is just absolutely
pouring yeah i mentioned that this is how bullet
can go sometimes robert you lose one you lose
two you might be a streak but in bullet it can
turn into ten games just like that so lars was
an incredible streak in the bullet portion and
that was just you know alone that's what
won him the match plain and simple rubber
yeah he was able to fend off some horrible
positions and he fought tooth and nail
that kind of defensive resource should
be praised we're gonna take a quick break
because when we return we'll be joined by
the players we'll get to hear their thoughts
on what was an exhilarating matchup between two
very strong competitors we shall be right back
and we return with the players uh alina our
apologies that the match not go your way and
congratulations to you lars and we'll start
with you lars what happened there how were
you able to turn it around you were down by four
points in the match what did you tell yourself
what did you change yeah at some point it was
looking really grim but i i kind of had the same
idea or planned over so much which was just
that i was go i was going to try to win every
game so the plan itself didn't change but it
was looking pretty hard at some point there
because in like the last five minute
games on the two first three games i
got crushed really i mean i i lost
like two drone and games as well
because i was trying to like press on time but um
after that i kept winning bad positions
and then like everything went my way
like except the openings like i was losing
after almost like 15 moves every game but
it went really well after the openings in the
last games yeah that's uh we thought maybe i
was gonna mention one of the openings that
you chose in particular that worked really
well the first time you tried it which was the
ortho schnapp that you uh you brought out and
uh credit to alina because it looked like she did
you check that alina in the break after the three
minute because he played it again in bullet and
it looked like you came with almost a refutation
oh no i didn't check the opening i i was happy
with what i was getting after the openings the
problem was not in this part of the game
but somehow i couldn't convert my winning
positions i mean and of course congratulations
to lars for for fighting so hard and i mean
yeah i mean especially that game when i was
pissed up and i lost it on time i mean that was
that was horrible from my site yeah and elena
at what point did you feel like the match was
slipping because you had the four point lead and
it seemed like you were getting great positions
and what happens one time maybe you can forget
about it but was it the second the third time
when did you really feel like things just were
falling apart uh i i felt bad when i lost the
fourth game in a row because it reminded me of the
game against of the match against john bartolome
last year when i lost six games in a row somehow
i should work on this stop losing click you know
stop at some point because i think in the third
game i lost i could after rook takes you three
i could just go for a draw and i don't know
where i but i started to blunder everything
and uh yeah at that point i thought that
i'm in trouble but then in one plus one uh
i i thought it was uh back in the game but uh
again i started i started to blunder at some point
and i couldn't stop that was a problem yeah that
the blunders obviously were they're hard to avoid
and and there are plenty i mean lars i have to ask
you because it seemed like a theme in this in this
match uh you had a bishop trapped on a8 trapped
on h8 i mean it's like you were addicted to these
what do you have to say about that yeah it's like
something that usually never happens and then i
got it like twice in this match uh or yeah twice
or three times um and like the first time i i just
blundered it but the time when i got the bishop on
a8 it was kind of intentional but it didn't didn't
really work out because i have no idea how that
position was like when the rick was on g8 like the
end game after exchange queens yeah robert and i
were actually having a a crazy time analyzing that
and watching it happen because believe it or not
alina played that to a point where it was actually
winning for white at many many points in that
end game and and obviously just dropping the rook
uh was the difference but i think that position
was actually better for white surprisingly
yeah yeah at the end i thought so too brian like
before i rendered like the a pawn i thought like i
should like i have three past ones but and i have
like the idea to take on c6 to get another one
but yeah about that position was really crazy
like i'm a piece on a couple of pawns up and
it's still like super hard for me in the end
game yeah well i know it's getting late for
you both but lars one last question you will face
the winner of teddy coleman and karissa yipp what
do you feel like you need to change so that you
can keep winning and moving on in this tournament
uh probably the openings the openings
went very poorly this much um
and maybe i've blundered a bit too much but i
think mainly the openings so i should just find
something that i'll play every game instead
of like switching between opening lines that
i don't know for sure that makes sense well lena
again our apologies the match can go your way but
you have so many fans out there who are rooting
you on so you should hang your head high and uh
you know be very proud and we're happy that you
participate in this event thank you good luck and
good luck for lars in the in the following
matches of course i'll be waiting for you
well here you heard their thoughts lars going
forward maybe he needs to fix something in
the opening and maybe stick to an opening that's
interesting and he will await the winner of teddy
coleman and carissa yip down in the bottom right
hand side of the bracket so amman as you look at
the bracket we still have a couple three first
round matchups to go and i don't know i don't
even know what to think right now after that fun
match that was awesome and and i said it right at
the beginning that maybe some people on uh twitch
aren't as familiar with the two competitors today
but in my opinion we've had some crazy ones
danny versus lawrence we've had levy rosman
you know tons and tons of uh fans uh on twitch
but i actually thought that this was seriously
the most entertaining match that um that we got
to witness and commenting on and people got to see
the personalities of the players as well i think
alina not only did she start with a lot of fans
as you mentioned but probably collected a few more
with uh with an ever gracious post-game interview
there you know wishing her uh competitor good luck
in the future rounds and actually cheering for him
to win the whole thing so that she can say yeah
you know i just lost to the winner second year
in a row that would be the case if lars is able to
move on and win this whole thing and i just wanted
to state that that match score is very misleading
i mean it looks like a lopsided affair it looks
like lars was just storming through and crushing
the match but no of course if you go back through
it there are many moments that both players
wish they could take back and i really just
was impressed i know i sound like mayor's
being a little bit harsh about lars's play
but the ability to not lose these completely
losing positions that is a talent in and of itself
and i don't say that lightly that is something you
see some of the best players in the world do like
even like the players the very top sometimes
hikaru nakamura gets a horrible position
and i'm just like wait still still fighting still
fighting wait a second he's turned this around
and he's winning the game so that kind of skill is
absolutely essential in a several hours long match
yep that's a great point now the clock is is part
of the match and you know there's always a best
move to be found no matter if if it's uh you know
good position few or a bad position so full credit
to lars and i think alina realized that as well
giving full credit to him for being so resilient
and not being too frustrated like oh man you
played like trash you were losing every game
we didn't see that attitude at all it was it was
more like wow that was actually very impressive
defense by lars so if he gets some better opening
positions that when he has those bad games he can
come back the way that he did in this match but
to get them less often to give himself a better
chance i could definitely be a front-runner for
potentially the finals in this tournament if
you keep that up yeah especially if he plays the
way he did in those first two games of the match
and then in the bullet portion i would say that
that was lars in full force and the orthoschnapp
game can't forget about that success that was his
best one for sure well on that note the match has
come to its conclusion we want to just remind
everybody that there will be so many more fun
events upcoming arena kings is in full swing we
will also have pogchamps 3 starting in february
not all of the players are known yet there
still are a few names to be announced
but just the players we have ensure that it will
be a great one amman hey man i have so much fun
commentating these matches for you this was the
most fun i've had yet yeah and we're getting lucky
because uh not only is it a good time anyway
but the matches that we've cut to commentate
have had evaluation bars that are basically
doing push-ups the entire time i mean up down
you name it the the matches have been exciting
they have been very close even though the final
score never seems to reflect that someone always
runs away with it at the end but all the matches
that we've commented have been exciting there's
just enough high level play and then just enough
blunders that it's the best of both worlds so
it's been a pleasure commentating alongside you
robert and of course we'll be we'll be back for
many more of these for sure and i just want to
say while the players they showed their nerves
of steel in this match particularly lars tata
steel resumes tomorrow you will not want to miss
the world's absolute best players taking on each
other head to head match-ups in classical time
controls dania naraditsky and fiona stanley tony
will have the call it's going to be another good
one so for now keep enjoying chess enjoy the rest
of your days but don't forget to tune back in for
that tournament once again tomorrow see everybody